Moin, was gucken? Wisst ihr, was heute angesagt ist? Außerhalb von Twitch, ich meine nicht auf Twitch.
Auch nicht PvP-Event. Wisst ihr, was heute angesagt ist? Deswegen muss ich nämlich auch gerade was gucken.
Heute ist wieder sprichwörtlich passives Gelddrucken angesagt. Und zwar, wie gesagt, im übertragenen Sinne.
Weil ich habe wieder Wochenendbereitschaften, es ist bis jetzt noch nichts passiert und ich kriege fett Stonks pro Tag.
Soll mir recht sein. Also es kann sein, dass ich eventuell angerufen werde und den Stream ausmachen muss.
Aber es ist doch rechtfertigt.
Nicht unwahrscheinlich. Wahrscheinlich so gut wie nie war es am Wochenende.
Aber es muss erreichbar sein. Stunde Reaktionszeit.
Und dann muss man halt am Rechner sein in der Zeit und deswegen kriegt man halt auch ordentlich Kohle.
Kannst du ja alles machen, was du willst.
Ich könnte heute Morgen beispielsweise nicht hier mal in die umliegenden Berge fahren, eine Runde wandern gehen.
Das wäre vielleicht ein bisschen unglücklich.
Ein bisschen suboptimal.
Aber.
Ansonsten gibt es fett Money fürs Nichts machen.
Im übertragenen Sinne kommt es, glaube ich, noch am nächsten an Gelddrucken.
Einfach da irgendwo am Rechner sitzen und streamen, sondern Geld verdienen.
Pogge.
Da sind wir dabei, Leute. Da sind wir dabei.
Ich bin noch früher als sonst, habt ihr vielleicht festgestellt.
Wegen daran, weil ich noch nicht Rennen war.
Ich bin mir noch nicht sicher, ob ich Rennen gehe heute.
Weil mir tut es beinahe noch ein bisschen weh von vor zwei Tagen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich da ein bisschen übertrieben habe.
Da war ich mir nicht ganz normal.
Also weder sonderlich schnell noch sonderlich langsam.
Auch die ganz normale Runde, nichts besonderes.
Keine Ahnung.
Ein bisschen schepp gelaufen oder so.
Entweder gehe ich schon nach dem Mittagessen oder gar nicht.
Guck, dann morgen oder so.
Weil Mittwoch muss ich nach Frankfurt.
Und wenn ich in Frankfurt bin, dann auch gleich mexikanisch Mittagessen.
Gleich ordentlich.
Das muss man ja mit ein paar vorteilhaften Sachen.
Verbinden.
Ich weiß.
Wir haben in letzter Zeit wenig Bastlostreams gemacht.
Aber ich hatte einfach keine Brainkapazitäten übrig.
Nebenarbeiten.
Bisschen YouTube Zeug machen.
Kreiselgrind.
Und ab und zu mal streamen.
Dann noch Five Hat IQ Content auf Twitch.
Hab ich nicht hingekriegt.
Wir müssen demnächst die Cloud Docker Kubernetes Challenge Webseite da fertig machen.
Wir müssen auch noch Set Server.
Ein paar Sachen erledigen.
Also es gibt auch immer mehr.
Es gibt auch immer mehr solcher solcher Challenge Seiten.
Da geht uns theoretisch der Content nicht aus.
Aber ich muss erst mal geistig in der Lage sein dazu gerade.
Das Video geht noch ein paar Minuten.
Okay, zeig her.
Ist das Linux Users Remove Plot.
Okay, lass mich mal prädikten, was in dem Video passiert.
Der Löt.
Wobei keine Ahnung.
Das ist es.
Das ist ein serieller Anschluss.
Dann von alles Notebook ausgebuddelt, wo es noch ein serieller Anschluss gibt.
Oder ist das USB auf Serial?
Weiß nicht, dass VGA.
Stimmt oder ist das?
Ich verwechsel das immer.
Ist VGA nicht 3 3 3 zeilig und das ist nur 2 zeilig.
Das müsste Serial sein.
Was sind sie bloß bloß ja ganz bestimmt heute Morgen.
So, wir gucken uns das jetzt mal 38 Sekunden.
Linux Users Removing Plotware hat das ist ein sehr reeller Anschluss, aber weil VGA hätte 3 hätte 3 3 Zeilen quasi 3 3 Reihen Pins Postchamp.
Ach, jetzt check ich, was er macht.
Jetzt check ich, was er macht.
Der macht so ein kleines Mini Display dran und wahrscheinlich ist alles andere entfernt.
Und bloatet, wobei das muss VGA sein.
Das muss VGA sein, weil erstens Display.
Ohne irgendwie Microcontroller dazwischen.
Und zweitens hat das Ding ein HDMI Ausgang, also Notebooks zu Zeiten mit Display Port und HDMI Ausgang.
Die hatten keine seriellen Schnittstellen mehr normalerweise.
Was? Was?
Neo Fetch, bloat, bloatware removed.
Ja, das ist auch geil.
Dass er das, dass er das Notebook ohne Display hat, was ich mich frage ist oder was mir so gar nicht klar war, ist.
Dass man diese Displays tatsächlich.
An einen VGA Ausgang anschließen kann, dass sie das, dass sie das verstehen.
Oder.
Spricht er den VGA Ausgang irgendwie custom mäßig an mit irgendeinem, wie auch immer man das macht.
Mit einer Custom Software.
Also mir war das nicht klar, dass sie das, dass sie das unterstützen.
Ich dachte, diese Displays können halt nur dieses, dieses, tja, frag mich nicht, dieses andere Zeugs da.
Interessant, dass das überhaupt geht.
Aber bloatware removed, mehr braucht man nicht.
100 mal 50 Pixel oder was haben die Dinger denn immer?
Keine Ahnung, 160 mal 100 oder irgendwie so.
Muss, muss genug sein.
Aber immerhin, man erkennt, dass es Neo Fetch ist von der Ausgabe.
Schon mal nice.
Aber gerade beim Thema sind.
Ich habe das auch gelesen, dass das an den Pins steht.
Aber VGA braucht ja normalerweise ein bisschen mehr.
Das ist das ganz normale, dass diese ganz normale Pin Belegung.
Die man beispielsweise auch an irgendeinem ESP32 verwendet.
Mit x beliebigen.
Ja, deswegen wundert es mich.
Dann ist das nämlich doch, dann ist das nämlich doch ein serielle, serielle.
Aber es ist drei, es ist drei.
Es ist drei reich, das Ding, das ist ein VGA Stecker.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie er das gemacht hat.
Vielleicht steht ja da was dran.
Ach, guck mal hier.
Ah, okay, Interact with I2C on Linux.
Alles klar.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, dann.
Aber über, über den.
Aber über den VGA Port.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein VGA Port.
Okay, anscheinend, anscheinend erlaubt das Linux.
Anscheinend erlaubt das Linux, dass man den VGA Port.
Gut, ich meine.
Wusste zwar nicht, dass das so ohne weiteres möglich ist,
die einzelnen Sachen, einzelnen Pins quasi von einem VGA Port anzusteuern.
Aber ist es anscheinend.
Das war mir auch nicht klar.
Oh, aber haben wir es gelernt.
Ist VGA auf jeden Fall.
So, wenn wir gerade dabei sind.
Ah ja, ja, guck mal, Command Line Weepshit.
Was ist, okay, Moment, One VPL, was habe ich da schon wieder installiert?
One, One VPL Runtime Implementation.
Ich weiß nicht, warum ich das installiert habe.
Wahrscheinlich als irgendeine Dependency.
Ich habe.
Absolut keine Ahnung.
Okay.
Ich mache mal Package Updates.
Einfach, weil ich das schon eine Weile nicht mehr gemacht habe.
Ich habe jetzt vor fünf, sechs Tagen zuletzt gestreamt.
Noch vor fünf Tagen, glaube ich.
Und nachdem unter 8 Linux natürlich übrigens hier mal mein Neo Fetch zum Vergleich.
Bisschen höher, mehr High Res als auf dem Mini Display.
Nachdem wir unter 8 Linux laufen.
Irgendwelche Package Updates kommen.
Vor allem QEMO ist gerade richtig dick dabei, so wie es aussieht.
Sollten wir das mal machen bei Gelegenheit hier.
So, und wenn wir Package Updates gemacht haben.
Dann brauchen wir noch Our Updates und dann.
Moin und dann brauchen wir noch Jetbrain Dings IDE Kram Updates.
Wir haben Kernel Updates dabei, also Our Packages.
Machen wir die Jetbrains Toolbox auf.
Ich hoffe, dass das jetzt nicht mehr meine VM abfuckt, wie das letzte Mal.
Installieren den Kram hier.
Rust Rover.
Brauche ich das überhaupt noch jemals wieder?
Ich aninstalle es einfach.
Keck wait.
Wenn wir irgendwann wieder Rust machen, dann werde ich es einfach wieder installieren.
So, Massive Passwort kommt hier nie drauf.
Update fertig.
Deswegen mag ich Arch Linux.
Das ist immer so schnell geupdatet.
Manch einer würde sagen, das ist auch so schnell kaputt geupdatet.
Aber da muss ich dagegen halten.
Ich hatte noch nie Probleme.
Mit Arch Linux Updates, obwohl das potenziell natürlich mehr unstable ist und und mehr
Probleme verursachen könnte, als jetzt beispielsweise ein Debian Update.
Aber hattet ihr schon mal Probleme für alle Arch Linux User by the way?
Also für das, dass das so aktuelle Software hat, ist das immer erstaunlich problemlos.
Muss dazu sagen, ich hatte zwar schon, ich hatte schon Probleme nach dem Update.
Vielleicht habe ich das falsch ausgedrückt.
Ich hatte aber noch nie Updates.
So nachdem.
Motto, dass das nicht mehr gebootet ist.
Probleme hatte ich nach Updates minimal auch schon.
Beispielsweise hatte ich mal eine Kernel Version, die hat in der VM einfach extrem geleckt.
Könnt ihr euch vielleicht noch daran erinnern, wo du, wo du teilweise hier den.
Oder was geschrieben hast und der hat zwischendrin immer gestoppt, so wie ich jetzt hier von Hand nachmache und dann erst weitergeschrieben.
Auch schon ein bisschen, ein bisschen verbuckt.
Update durch.
Checken, ob AskIquarium noch funktioniert.
Allerwichtigste.
Nice funktioniert.
Geht exzellent.
Blazing fast.
One second Refresh Rate.
Exzellent.
So GitHub, schauen wir mal, was diese Woche trendet.
Ich werde alles mit AI wieder skippen.
Du hast schon mal Arch zerschossen durch Updates.
TSFox, danke für 20 Monate Massive Subscription.
Es gab doch vor nicht allzu langer Zeit.
Oh, vielleicht erinnert sich da jemand dran.
Ein Problem mit dem.
Mit Krupp.
Wenn man Krupp verwendet hat als Boot Manager, da gab es doch ein Problem bei Arch Linux.
Oder war das so ein Problem bei Manjaro damals?
Vielleicht membert der ein oder andere.
Das hat ja ein paar Installationen geschrottet, weil das irgendwie nicht bootbare Krupp Menü Einträge oder irgendwie sowas im Kopf gar nicht mehr hin erzeugt hat.
Ich weiß nicht mal, was das war, aber zumindest ich hatte es unter meiner vor allem nicht, weil ich verwende ja kein Krupp.
Ich verwende ja Chat, was verwende ich eigentlich?
Das ist das System System Boot System Boot D ist das ist das System Boot D also nicht Krupp auf jeden Fall.
Das System System D Boot D oder wie das heißt oder System D Boot.
Glaube, das ist System.
Es gibt doch, es gibt doch, es gibt doch so neuen Boot Manager, der in letzter Zeit recht beliebt ist.
Wie heißt denn das Ding nochmal?
Es gibt Krupp, es gibt System D Boot und.
Und dann gibt es noch was drittes, was in letzter Zeit so auf Reddit Reddit Unix Porn beliebt ist, wo die Leute immer erzählen, was sie verwenden.
Ich habe es nicht Lilo.
Lilo war vor 30 Jahren 20 Jahren beliebt.
Weiß ich gar nicht.
Gibt es das überhaupt?
Noch das war gut.
Lilo Boot Loader GitHub wird das noch entwickelt.
Bin mir nicht so ganz sicher, ob das top aktuell ist.
Tatsächlich.
Vor sechs Jahren OpenSUSE Lilo ja, null Sterne spricht für die Beliebtheit.
Denn du darf danke für den SAP und Panda POG Subscriptions Leute.
Hast du schon mal mit Webstorm gearbeitet?
Ja.
Das war ausingeniert, bedeutet, hat keiner mehr Bock, sich drum zu kümmern.
Es ist es ist X ist X11 auch aus X Org auch ausingeniert, weil dann auch keiner Bock, weiß ich, ob man, ob man X Org ingeniert nennen kann von dem, was man da so liest.
Ja, aber ich habe schon mal mit Webstorm gearbeitet.
Ja.
Geht mir genauso.
Battleship.
Guck mal.
Ich habe von Jet Brains.
Ich habe da Flameshot noch installiert.
Das benutze ich überhaupt nicht.
Ich habe hier von Jet Brains.
Ach guck mal, ich darf das Fenster wieder bewegen, ohne dass meine VM abkackt.
Ist ja auch sehr nett.
So, ich habe von Jet Brains dieses All Desktop Package und du hast ja eben gesehen, ich hatte eben noch die neue Rusty.
Ach, ist sie jetzt raus?
Ist sie nicht mehr Alpha?
Rust Rover ist jetzt offiziell, ist sie jetzt offiziell oder ist sie noch Alpha?
Nee, das ist noch Alpha, steht bloß nicht dran.
Also, was ich in letzter Zeit verwendet habe von Jet Brains, hier ist Rider für C-Sharp, das ist eigentlich das, was ich am meisten von denen verwende.
Ich finde, Rider hat wirklich, also bei mir wirklich richtig eingeschlagen.
Da brauche ich kein Windows mehr für .NET Entwicklung.
Man hätte zwar theoretisch vorher auch schon kein Windows für .NET Entwicklung gebraucht, solange es .NET Core gab oder gibt, beziehungsweise früher gab es ja noch Mono und Monodevelop.
Das ging auch irgendwie.
Aber schön war was anderes.
Aber Visual Studio Code mit .NET ist halt, auch wenn die letztens, glaube ich, ein neues .NET Plugin bekommen haben, nicht so geil.
Und Rider hat halt dazu geführt, dass ich .NET Entwicklung nur noch unter Linux mache, seit Jahren schon.
Rider ist das Beste.
So, PyCharm ab und zu ein bisschen Python Zeug.
Warum ich die Professional Version habe von PyCharm, kann ich euch auch erklären.
Das ist aus höchst seriösen Professional Programming Gründen.
Das ist, weil ich das Abo abgeschlossen habe.
Und weil es geht.
Nicht, weil ich irgendwelche Features davon bräuchte.
So, Goland für Go.
Und dann hatte ich letztens noch Rust, Rust Rover am Start für Rust.
Ansonsten, was ich sonst noch davon verwendet habe, ist Ruby Mine.
Tatsächlich, früher.
In letzter Zeit nicht mehr, weil ich in letzter Zeit nichts mehr in Ruby mache.
IntelliJ, IntelliJ musste ich letztens für irgendwas, ich habe es vergessen, Chatge, wir haben das doch im Stream verwendet.
Für irgendein, ach Kotlin, Kotlin.
Wir haben ja ein bisschen Kotlin gebastelt.
Bastelt vor einem dreiviertel Jahr oder so.
IntelliJ.
So.
Datacrypt habe ich irgendwann mal installiert und gedacht, das ist viel zu Overkill für mich.
CLion habe ich tatsächlich schon das eine oder andere Mal verwendet.
Aber WebStorm, WebStorm habe ich auch benutzt.
Und ich muss dir ehrlich sagen, Battlesheet, mir ging es da wie dir.
Ich bin ja, was Frontend Sachen angeht, hauptsächlich, hauptsächlich, genau, auch an Visual Studio Code gewöhnt.
Und ich habe mir dann überlegt, okay, was für Vorteile hat jetzt WebStorm für mich?
Und ich habe auf den ersten Blick keine gesehen und deswegen verwende ich auch kein WebStorm.
Ich habe es auch nicht installiert, obwohl ich das All Desktop Package habe und den anderen Chatbrains Krempel verwende.
So könnte man eigentlich sagen, ich verwende für alles Serverseitige halt Chatbrains, IDEs oder für irgendwelche Command Line Tools oder sonstige Sachen, ja.
Und für Frontend Sachen.
Visual Studio Code.
Was ich auch noch Visual Studio Code verwende, ist Plattform IO Microcontroller Krempel.
Das habe ich mal probiert in CLion.
Das hat aber nicht so gut funktioniert.
Ging aber auch.
So, so sieht es aus.
Nutzt du Wayland als Desktop Environment?
Pass mal auf, pass mal auf.
Ich glaube, das beantwortet es.
Jetzt hat mein Desktop Hintergrund keinen Bock mehr.
Ah ja, hier, da ist er.
Frühstücks-Pepo am Start.
Moin.
Bist du gespannt auf Fleet?
Ja, ich bin seit Beta oder Vorschau oder wie auch immer das hieß, gespannt auf Fleet.
Ich glaube aber nicht, dass sich da so viel tun wird, weil es hat sich die letzten zwei Jahre nichts getan.
Und ich hätte zur Zeit echt keine Ahnung, für was ich Fleet überhaupt verwenden sollte.
Und diese, also, das nimmt ja nur Fahrt auf.
Wenn die Leute, auch wie du sagst, schon Plugins entwickeln können.
Visual Studio Code hat sich aus mehreren Gründen durchgesetzt.
Erstens, weil Microsoft das richtig gut supportet.
Weil es einer der wenigen JavaScript Editoren ist, der zu dieser Zeit entstanden ist.
Den man benutzen kann, ohne einzuschlafen dabei.
Beziehungsweise ohne, dass es rumruckelt und laggt.
Und Input Delay hat und alles mögliche.
Und, weil es JavaScript für Plugins hat.
Und es Gott um die Welt an Plugins gibt.
Für Visual Studio Code.
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr was witzig ist?
Das einzige, was es nicht gibt, das ist eigentlich richtig, richtig weird, ja.
Das einzige, was es nicht richtig gescheit gibt, ist ein Browser Plugin für Visual Studio Code.
Obwohl Visual Studio Code selber ein Browser ist.
Versteht das irgendjemand? Ich verstehe das nicht.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Irgendeinen Grund muss es ja haben.
Aber ist schon lustig, ne?
Dass es in einem Browser, es keinen Browser gibt.
Also mein, davon abgesehen.
Brauchen, brauchen tue ich einen Browser Plugin Visual Studio Code beim besten Willen nicht.
Ich mein, wozu sollte ich einen Browser Plugin brauchen?
Mach mal Visual Studio Code mal auf, so.
Und wenn ich jetzt Frontend Sachen machen will.
Dann starte ich einfach Chrome.
Und ob das jetzt ein Tab im Visual Studio ist.
Oder ein Tab hier.
Also.
Ist jetzt nicht so, als macht es einen großen Unterschied, ja.
Max, darf ich dir mal eine Frage stellen?
Es ist eine Aufgabe aus der Schule.
Auf geht's.
Okay.
Ich habe gesehen, es gibt Leute, die versuchen das auf ähnliche Art und Weise, einen Browser in Visual Studio Code zu bringen.
Die streamen quasi eine Background Chromium Instanz da als Bilder irgendwie rein.
Ganz furchtbar weirder Kram.
Das ist natürlich Performance mäßig auch nicht so geil.
Und ich habe auch noch nicht so genau verstanden, warum.
Aber es gibt Visual Studio Code im Browser.
Das ist richtig, ja.
Was übrigens sehr nice ist und die neuen GitLab Versionen auch Visual Studio Code als Web Editor verwenden.
Äh, nicht GitHub, GitLab.
Hab ich GitHub? Ach, keine Ahnung.
GitLab meine ich.
Das Weltplugin für Websoft ist auch nicht so pralle.
Ja.
Mag sein.
Glaube ich dir sofort.
Auf, schieß los mit der Frage aus der Schule.
Wir gucken uns jetzt, bis die Frage aus der Schule hier ankommt.
Mann, je nachdem.
Wir machen jetzt nicht, wir machen jetzt nicht die Hausaufgaben, ja.
Wie benutzt man einen Schlüssel, um eine Verbindung abzusichern?
Ey, das könnte ja fast eine IHK-Frage sein, so kontextlos ist die.
Die ist komplett, die ist komplett kontextlos, die Frage, Alter.
Wie benutzt man einen Schlüssel, um eine Verbindung abzusichern?
Nachdem sie von Verbindung sprechen, ver...
Ey, keine Ahnung.
Das, das, also ohne Kontext ist das nicht zu beantworten.
Aber was habt ihr denn in der Schule gemacht in letzter Zeit?
Ich mein, da kann man sich ja vielleicht draus, draus erschließen.
Aber ohne, ohne Kontext ist das, ist das nicht zu beantworten.
Man, man könnte vermuten, dass sie halt eine, nennen wir es mal laienhaft ausgedrückt,
Netzwerkverbindung meinen.
Also sprich, irgendwas im Browser zum Beispiel.
Also ich mein, Netzwerkverbindung ist ja, ist ja die, die genericste Bezeichnung ever.
Ja.
Und normalerweise verschlüsselst du ja auch gar nicht auf Verbindungsebene.
Sondern du verschlüsselst auf...
Tja.
Das ist schwierig zu sagen.
Auf welcher Ebene verschlüsselt TLS?
Das ist nicht wirklich Anwendung.
Das ist eigentlich schon eher auf...
Eins auf TCP drauf.
Also quasi...
Wenn man das nach dem OSI-Modell macht, dann auf Schicht...
Äh...
Vier?
Fragezeichen, Leute?
Ist das nicht vier?
Das ist schon so weile her.
Nee, Session ist glaube ich sechs oder fünf.
Wart mal.
Okay.
Passt mal auf.
Nicht, nicht sagen, nicht sagen.
Ich will mal gucken.
Ich will mal gucken, ob ich die OSI, die OSI-Modell-Layer zusammen kriege.
Also.
Please.
Do.
Not.
Throw.
Salami.
Pizza.
Away.
Irgendwie so.
Ging das doch.
Gell?
Dieser Merksatz für OSI-Modell.
Also.
P.
Physical.
D.
Ich glaube auf Deutsch heißt das Bit-Übertragungsschicht.
Ich glaube das heißt sowas wie...
Nee.
Das ist Bit-Übertragungsschicht.
Ähm.
Wart mal.
Das ist...
Datalink.
Genau.
So.
Session.
Application.
P.
Fällt mir jetzt nicht ein.
Presentation.
Ah.
Ja.
Genau.
Das ist das, was total vage ist.
Presentation.
Ja.
Genau.
Falsch.
Wieso ist das falsch?
Ist doch richtig.
Ich hab doch genau...
Ihr habt das doch auch gut aus dem Kopf hingekriegt.
Ist doch alles richtig.
Wobei.
Ich bin mir...
Ich bin mir da gar nicht so ganz sicher.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Aus dem Kopf.
Wie das...
Auf welcher...
Genau.
TLS ansetzt.
Also.
Es kann ja nicht TCP sein, weil TCP Handshakes und sowas.
Das passiert ja alles.
Das müsste also eins oben drüber sein.
Also müsste das wahrscheinlich Schicht 5 sein.
Jetzt hab ich natürlich meins hier gelöscht.
Schicht 5 ist...
Session.
Ja.
Also auf Session-Ebene müsste...
Nee.
Müsste TLS sein.
TLS.
Ich kann mir das...
Ich kann mir das immer...
Immer schlecht merken.
Also.
Beim Verbindungsaufbau...
Warte mal.
Warum ist das so laut gerade?
Ist das gar nicht...
Also.
Bei einem Verbindungsaufbau.
Zum Beispiel hier.
Wenn ich jetzt...
Wenn ich jetzt ein Web-Request mache zu Twitch.
Die Seite ist hier...
Ah.
DTPS.
Ist es ja so.
Das erstmal eine...
Also erstmal logischerweise DNS-Namensauflösung dahin.
Dann TCP Handshake mit dem Server auf der anderen Seite.
So.
Dann wird...
Über diese bestehende TCP-Verbindung.
Wird ein...
Wie heißt das?
Zumindest passiert das in 90% der Fälle heutzutage.
Wird ein...
Ein...
So eine Art Hostname mitgeschickt.
Das heißt nicht Hostname.
Das heißt irgendwie anders.
Zertifikatsname oder sowas.
Was ist denn da Krampel?
Also so dass du quasi mehrere Sachen auf...
Also mehrere...
TLS Sachen auf einer Kiste laufst.
SNI.
Genau das meine ich.
Ja.
Wird...
Wird mitgeschickt.
Anhand dessen weiß der Server quasi...
Das ist so eine Art...
Das ist sowas wie Host in HTTP quasi.
Anhand dessen weiß der Server wo du hin willst.
Und dann macht er da drauf halt seinen Verschlüsselungs...
Tja.
Key...
Key-Austausch erst mit...
Asynchronem Verschlüsselungskram.
Asynchronem Schlüsselaustausch.
Und dann Verbindung aufgebaut.
Und dann macht er sein HTTP-Request drüber.
Ja.
Name-Indication.
Genau das meine ich.
Soweit...
Soweit ich das aus dem Kopf zusammen kriege.
So.
Und jetzt auf die Frage jetzt zurückzukommen.
Wie benutzt man...
Wie benutzt man einen Schlüssel um eine Verbindung abzusichern?
Es ist so vage und so kontextlos.
Das kann man an der Stelle echt nicht beantworten.
Also was habt ihr denn in der Schule gemacht?
Das...
Was man da...
Nicht asynchron.
Asymmetrisch.
Ja meine ich.
Es ist ja fast schon IHK...
IHK Level die Frage.
Wie benutzt man einen Schlüssel um eine Verbindung abzusichern?
Nein die...
Ich meine das kann ja von allem...
Das kann sein.
Wie hinterlege ich einen eigenen Key in PuTTY?
Zu...
Wie funktioniert das wirklich auf Netzwerkebene?
Das kann man...
Also...
Keine Ahnung.
Das kann man ohne Kontext nicht beantworten.
Aber ganz ohne Kontext wird die Frage ja nicht gestellt sein oder?
Ja.
Du kannst den Serverraum damit abschließen mit dem Schlüssel.
Visual Studio Code?
Visual Studio Code auf meinem Home Server?
Du meinst den Browser?
Ja.
Kann man machen.
Ich meine...
Aber wenn ich irgendwas editieren will auf dem iPad, dann würde ich irgendeinen Code-Editor
oder irgendeinen Text-Editor auf dem iPad...
Ganz ehrlich.
Ich würde eh Anfälle bekommen auf dem iPad was programmieren zu müssen.
Okay.
Wir googeln das jetzt mal.
Wir machen das jetzt was der Chat vorschlägt.
Ja gut.
Die erklären was von Public und Private Key und sowas.
Thema ist Security, Begriff und Verschlüsselungsverfahren.
Ja gut.
Dann weiß man ja schon in welche Richtung es ist.
Und dann hattet ihr sicherlich im Unterricht auch was, wo man weiß auf was sich die Frage
bezieht.
So ganz...
Also ganz...
Selbst das ist super kontextlos.
Security, Begriff und Verschlüsselungsverfahren.
Ist das der deutsche Merksatz?
Anwendungsschicht?
Ne.
Sicherungsschicht?
Bindung?
Ich kann mir die Dinger nicht merken.
Und was ist Layer 8?
Du meinst den Twitch Chat?
Ich habe den Eindruck, du hast nicht aufgepasst.
Drängt sich mir so auf.
Okay, weil man mit IPsec anfängt, hat man eh schon verloren.
Der Kontext ist das.
Okay.
Wie erstellt man ein Schlüssel...
Aha.
Ja, da kommen wir doch der Sache schon deutlich näher.
Da kommen wir der Sache doch schon deutlich näher.
Okay.
Also.
Wie erstellt man ein Schlüsselpaar und oder eine OpenID?
Was OpenID ist, weiß ich nicht.
Klingt nach irgend sowas wie OAuth oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Wie benutzt man einen Schlüssel, um eine E-Mail zu verschlüsseln?
Ah, ja.
Wie benutzt man einen Schlüssel, um eine E-Mail zu entschlüsseln?
Wie benutzt man einen Schlüssel, um eine Nachricht zu signieren?
Wie benutzt man einen Schlüssel, um eine Verbindung abzunehmen?
Ja.
Okay.
Hier ist der Kontext ja klar.
Ihr hattet wahrscheinlich im Unterricht OpenID.
Und...
Ja.
Und der will das jetzt eher aus Anwendungssicht wissen.
Der will nicht, dass ihr erklärt, wie das funktioniert, sondern zumindest lese ich das
so raus.
Der will wissen, wie man beispielsweise, nachdem man sich wie auch immer eine OpenID generiert
hat, ich kenne OpenID nicht, und bei OpenID erhält man dann wahrscheinlich ein paar Key
Files, wie man das, ja, in, in, ja, was auch immer, Thunderbird oder wo auch immer, da
wo auch immer, hinterlegt, um das zu verschlüsseln.
Aber das hattet ihr ja wahrscheinlich, ne?
Also ich habe keine Ahnung, was OpenID ist.
Und wenn nicht, solltet ihr es vielleicht daheim rauskriegen.
Was ist denn OpenID?
Keine Ahnung.
Chatge, kennt irgendjemand OpenID?
Was ist das?
OpenID ist ein dezentrales Authentifizierungssystem
für webbasierte Dienste.
Alter, das ist ja, also mehr generic kann die Einleitung
jetzt ja auch nicht sein, oder?
Oder? Ist das irgendeine deutsche Login-with-Google-Alternative, oder was?
Okay.
OpenID ist ein dezentrales Authentifizierungssystem...
SL... Okay.
Ja, Singles, also irgend sowas wie OAuth oder sowas.
OpenID.net habe ich noch nie gehört, ey.
Habe ich noch nie gehört. Keine Ahnung.
Für die Anmeldung mit OpenID...
Es ist irgendein Authentifizierungs-Provider-Gedöns, ja.
Also im Prinzip...
So ein bisschen sowas wie Login-with-Google,
Login-with-Facebook, Login-with-GitHub und sowas.
Irgendeine OAuth-Geschichte,
hätte ich jetzt auch gedacht.
Ja, OAuth.
Ja.
Aber...
Also benutzt? Keine Ahnung.
Habe ich das noch nicht.
Ich meine,
der wird euch doch die Frage nicht einfach,
ohne dass ihr was gemacht habt, so vor Nutz klatschen.
Ja, das muss ja doch schon ein bisschen drum gegangen sein.
Also das sieht aber eindeutig
aus Anwendersicht aus, wie er das wissen will.
Also, oder?
Wie seht ihr das Chat?
Also ich finde, in dem Kontext
klingen die Fragen nicht danach,
erklären sie, wie
Private-Public-Key-TLS-Gedöns funktioniert
oder Zertifikate,
sondern hier wollen sie wissen,
nachdem ich den OpenID-Assistent durchgeklickt habe,
was auch immer, wie das aussieht,
wie richte ich mein Thunderbird ein,
um E-Mails zu verschlüsseln,
um E-Mails zu entschlüsseln,
wie signiere ich damit Nachrichten
oder halt mit irgendeinem E-Mail,
oder halt mit irgendetwas,
wegen der Software, die ihr im Unterricht hattet.
Keine Ahnung, was ihr da für ein E-Mail-Programm verwendet.
Echt, was ist das für eine Schule?
Also was machst du da?
Würde mich auch mal interessieren,
so den Kontext von,
ist das noch quasi irgendwie Realschule, Abitur?
Ist das Berufsschule?
Ist das irgendwie, was gibt es da sonst noch?
Fachabi oder so, was ist das?
Ja, aber gut.
Ich meine, mit ein bisschen Nachgucken
kann man die Frage schon beantworten.
Techniker-Schule.
Mit ein bisschen Nachgucken
kann man die Frage schon beantworten.
Man muss jetzt noch wissen,
auf was sich das bezieht.
Wenn nicht dabei steht,
wie benutzt man eine Schlüssel,
um eine E-Mail zu signieren,
dann würde ich mir einfach raussuchen,
wie man es beispielsweise mit Thunderbird macht.
So ist hier Thunderbird, OpenID.
Ich meine, auf die Idee bist du wahrscheinlich
selbst schon gekommen.
Und da liest ihr durch,
wie der Krempel funktioniert.
Falls das geht.
Und dann klickt man wahrscheinlich,
keine Ahnung, habe ich noch nicht gemacht,
aber das klickt man schon mit ein bisschen Googlen raus.
Okay, ChatG, wir wollten ChatGPD.
Chat, Chat, nicht ChatGPD.
Wie komme ich da?
Ich weiß nicht, ob jemand geschrieben hat im Chat.
GitHub.
Wir wollten GitHub-Trends die Woche gucken.
Und ich werde wieder alles mit AI überspringen.
ChatGPD.
Die haben dann random Anzeigen auf dieser Map,
wo das Auto gerade ist.
Die sind wahrscheinlich genauer
als das echte Tracking von DPD.
Also es geht los mit CrewAI.
Also der Name hört sich schon so an.
Also immer.
Als ist AI und so.
AI.
Alter, ist das Pfeil fett.
Was?
What?
Okay, Chat, 5 Punkte.
Wer checkt, um was es hier geht?
Mobile Aloha.
Learning by manual mobile manipulation
with low cost whole body teleoperation.
Easy, oder?
Obviously.
Irgendeine Microcontroller-Geschichte?
Ich habe, ich habe absolut keine Ahnung,
man, was das ist.
Chatbot UI, okay.
Weg.
Facebook AI-Zeug,
um Gesichter zu erzeugen,
oder so.
Krempe, ja, genau.
Free and open source Manga-Reader
for Android.
Ja, sind die, das ist die,
die exzellente Weeb-App.
Java-Programmierübung.
AI, AI,
AI,
vermute ich mal.
nee, irgendwelches
Security-Zeug vielleicht?
AI,
Android-Hackerman-Zeug,
Maui.
Warum trendet Maui?
Ich warte jeden Tag auf den Blog-Post von Microsoft,
dass Maui eingestellt wird.
Irgendjemand von euch, der wirklich Maui verwendet,
der vielleicht im .NET-Umfeld ist,
der wirklich Maui verwendet?
Oder sagen wir mal so,
der Maui verwenden muss,
okay, ich sage es noch präziser,
irgendjemand von euch im .NET-Umfeld,
der Maui verwendet,
schrägstrich verwenden muss und es mag?
Fragezeichen.
Ich habe das ja letzten schon mal gefragt
und da hatten wir ein paar Leute,
die noch Xamarin.Forms verwenden müssen
und das auch schon kotzen
und Maui ist ja quasi rebranded.
Okay, Blazingly Fast, written in Rust.
Das ist, die, die Rust,
das Rust, das Rust-Projekt hier ist so high IQ,
ich weiß noch nicht mal, was es bedeuten soll.
DataFrames powered by a multithreaded vectorized
query engine.
Alles klar, Leute, DataFrames, Polars.
Es muss wahrscheinlich Polar-AS sein.
Blazingly Fast DataFrames.
Polars is a DataFrame interface on top of the
OLAP Query Engine.
Ich weiß nicht, was das tut.
Datenbank-Zeug, Datenbank-Zeug, ich check's nicht,
aber das ist zu high IQ für mich.
Unix like kernel written in Rust.
Okay.
Ein weiteres Projekt der Kategorie
Rust-Community löst Probleme, die es nicht gibt,
aber jeder, was er mit seiner,
kann jeder mit seiner Zeit machen, was er will.
Äh, AI.
YouTube-Stells.
React, Frontend, Pocketbase.
Das ist keine Datenbank, oder?
Das kommt mir auch bekannt vor.
Das, das, das hab ich schon mal gesehen.
Pocketbase sagt mir irgendwas.
Ach, das ist die Geschichte,
dass quasi
so,
so ein bisschen Firebase mäßig nur im Kleinen.
Läuft das Archiv nicht damit, Max, bist du da?
Läuft das Archiv mit Pocketbase?
Das alte Archiv läuft mit irgendeinem Postgres im Hintergrund, dachte ich.
React vorne, Burn, AI, okay, weg.
Facechain, Deep Learning.
Okay, heute waren, heute waren nur 80% AI.
Nice.
Mal ganz schnell, weil wir immer, weil ich immer, wenn man dreht, was trennt so in der C-Sharp-Welt?
Maui, kotzen, Alter.
Power Toys, okay, gut.
Azure SDK, okay, ich fall's.
Pias, oder, oder PS.
PSNG.
Chinakinesen-Crap.
Collects Crap in VR, was soll das sein?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
F-Home.
Ja, braucht keiner.
Counter-Strike Sharp.
Counter-Strike Sharp allows you to write server plugins.
In C-Sharp for Counter-Strike 2.
Nice, okay.
Irgendwelche Leute hier noch CS'er, aber da gibt's jetzt, da gibt's demnächst dann auch Prop Hunt und so Zeug in,
in CS, wobei, die gibt's wahrscheinlich schon.
Joa, nicht so spannend, ne?
Gut, dann machen wir die Lenungskiste mal wieder aus, die brauchen wir jetzt ja nicht.
Jetgear.
Und,
ah, ja, erst mal aufwärmen.
Avalonia-Stream haben wir schon, wir haben ein bisschen mit Avalonia rumgebastelt mal irgendwann.
Guck.
Das ist das Schöne, dass wir das Archiv am Start haben.
Ups.
Archiv.
Dass wir das Archiv am Start haben.
Vaublois Archiv.
Äh.
Avalonia.
Ava...
Wenn man das so richtig schreiben würde.
Ja.
Vor sechs Monaten, okay, das ist tatsächlich schon ein bisschen...
Hast du mal YARP angeschaut?
Ja, hab ich letztens.
Und da ist mir aufgefallen, es ist ein reiner...
ähm...
...HTTP, also es kann nur HTTP, es kann...
...nix anderes.
Da hab ich's nicht weiterverendet.
Ja.
Hier haben wir tatsächlich in Avalonia was gebaut.
Bisschen rumgebastelt.
Aller beste, beste App überhaupt, ja.
Aber wir haben ja wieder Zeit.
Wir haben ja wieder Zeit, ich glaube, ich glaube, da gibt's mittlerweile schon mehr.
Das sechs Monate, bei Avalonia tut sich sehr viel.
In letzter Zeit.
Ja.
Hm, das wollte ich jetzt eigentlich sagen.
Ja, Chat, gab's die Woche noch irgendwas, was ich irgendwie verdrängt hab?
Äh, dass...
Dass Fritzboxen verboten wurden, hab ich...
What the fuck?
Dass Fritzboxen verboten wurden, hab ich ein Video zugemacht, was enorm gut angekommen ist.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Es hat innerhalb von einem Tag fast 50.000 Aufrufe bekommen.
Weil...
...die Leute Fritzboxen mögen, glaube ich.
Das ist mein meist aufgeruftes Video...
...in langer Zeit, innerhalb von einem Tag...
...nicht insgesamt...
...auf...
...aber innerhalb von einem Tag...
...ist es...
...habe ich in letzter Zeit kein anderes Video hochgeladen, was so viele Aufrufe bekommen hat.
Der Titel ist, glaube ich, ganz nice, ja.
Natürlich sind die Leute teilweise wieder drauf angesprungen, so nach dem Motto...
...so ein scheiß Clickbait-Titel.
Wobei man sagen muss, ich hab ja das ziemlich genau...
...ähm...
...ja, wiedergegeben.
Ja, wiedergegeben, wie die aktuelle Situation ist.
Und laut dem Gerichtsurteil ist das das Ende der Fritzbox, wie wir sie kennen.
Die Newsseiten waren sich nicht darüber einig, ob das jetzt schon alles enforced wird oder nicht.
Ja, um olle Fritzboxen geht's nicht.
Es geht nur um halbwegs moderne Fritzboxen mit WiFi 6.
Und da witzigerweise auch nicht alle komplett.
Was ich ein bisschen weird finde, ist...
...dass...
...das ist hier, glaube ich, sogar verlinkt...
...was ich ein bisschen weird finde, ist...
...dass AVM...
...Firmwares released hat...
...mit der gleichen Versionsnummer...
...die...
...man sieht das hier irgendwas mit Felder.
Genau, guck hier.
Änderung, Anpassung von Signal...
...das ist die Änderung, um die es da geht...
...um die es da geht und wo es um die Patentstreitigkeiten geht.
Änderung, Anpassung von Signalisierungsfeldern bei WiFi 6.
Also sprich...
...die Version hier gibt's zweimal.
Einmal mit diesem Update und einmal ohne diesem Update.
Das ist natürlich ein bisschen...
...ein bisschen doof, ne?
Weil, man könnte jetzt ja argumentieren...
...Versionsnummern sind eigentlich dafür da, dass man sowas unterscheiden kann.
Du hättest eine Videoidee, ja? Dann schieß los.
Nee, nee, ich glaube nicht, dass das der Azubi vergessen hat.
Ich glaube, das ist Absicht.
Und zwar...
...vielleicht, dass man entweder nicht richtig nachvollziehen kann...
...also gerade Huawei nicht richtig nachvollziehen kann...
...wer das jetzt verwenden will nicht...
...dass sie nicht sagen können, retroaktiv hier...
...wir bekommen von euch jetzt so und so viel Geld noch...
...und auch, dass die Leute, die schon geupdatet haben...
...nicht einfach nur updaten müssen...
...nochmal neu, um das gleiche zu bekommen...
...nur mit einem Feature deaktiviert.
Das ist bestimmt Absicht, wenn ich's auch ein bisschen weird finde, ehrlich gesagt.
Hab noch eine Tasmota-Frage.
Was spricht gegen Tasmota-Geräte vom Gebrauchtmarkt zu holen?
Eigentlich nix.
Das einzige, was vielleicht der Theorie dagegen spricht, ist...
...wenn man davon ausgeht, dass China-Chinesen Elektronikgeräte...
...vielleicht eh schon nicht unbedingt die beste Bildqualität haben...
...und vielleicht nicht so lange halten...
...dass man nicht irgendwelche kaputten Geräte kauft...
...so nach dem Lotto, die Leute sagen, ey, ich hab keinen Bock mehr...
...weil das nicht richtig funktioniert...
...und die verkaufen das...
...und du kannst nicht richtig feststellen im Vorfeld, dass es kaputt ist.
Also, aber ansonsten eigentlich nix.
Was du aber auch machen kannst, ist, es gibt ja Hersteller mittlerweile...
...die fertige Tasmota-geflashte Geräte anbieten.
Das finde ich ganz sinnvoll.
Wenn man nix mal findet.
Am besten ist immer noch diese billig China-Chinesen Steckdosenleiste von Hammer...
...die die ja nicht selbst gebaut haben, die gibt's ja von tausend verschiedenen Herstellern...
...die haben aber so eine olle Firma-Version drauf, bei Hammer...
...dass man die noch OTA-flashen kann.
Dark Zone, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Wie Open Source für Basis-Infra-Geschichten dafür sorgt...
...dass einem ein Hersteller nicht massiv in die Suppe spucken kann.
Du meinst so nach dem Motto...
...man kauft sich jetzt was von Oracle oder SAP...
...und die stellen fest bei einer Lizenzprüfung...
...dass du 3 Millionen Lizenzgebühren nachzahlen musst oder so...
...und da hast du keinen Bock drauf?
Oder du hast ein Produkt und die stellen den Support ein oder sowas in der Richtung...
...dass sie das nicht so einfach bei einem verbreiteten Open Source-Produkt...
...passieren.
Die Broadcom-VMWer-Übernahme.
Echt? Da habe ich überhaupt nichts von mitgekriegt.
Was ist denn da?
VMWer stellt...
...altes...altes...äh Schwachsinn.
Nicht.
VMWer stellt...
Broadcom stellt VMWer-Zeug ein oder wie ist das?
Ich habe damit überhaupt keine Berührungspunkte.
Deswegen weiß ich nicht, was da so abgeht.
Wir benutzen natürlich auch auf der Arbeit VMWer-Produkte...
...aber damit habe ich nichts zu tun, was administrationstechnisch angeht.
Wie automatisch wird bei größeren Anwendungen eigentlich versioniert?
Das kommt auf das Team, den Workflow und die Anwendung an.
In der Regel würde ich sagen...
...ist die Frage, wie man es machen will.
Komplett automatisches Versionieren kannst du machen...
...aber für Release-Versionen würde ich immer einen manuellen Tag oder irgendwie sowas anstreben.
Macht ja keinen Sinn zu sagen...
...das letzte Comet, was Freitag um 8 Uhr committet wird...
...wird jetzt unsere nächste Release-Version oder so.
Das macht ja keinen Sinn.
Release-Versionen, die müssen schon manuell getaggt werden...
...und dementsprechend dann auch nochmal getestet werden...
...bevor sie released werden.
Was man machen kann, was oftmals ganz sinnvoll ist...
...ist tatsächlich irgendeine Bildnummer.
Hinten dran.
Oder wie auch immer man es machen will.
Einfach, dass man selbst gucken kann...
...was benutze ich denn genau.
Weil es kann ja durchaus sein, dass derjenige, der das testet...
...nicht derjenige ist, der sich den Source Code ausgecheckt hat...
...genau weiß, welche Version das ist und das dann startet.
Also irgendeine Bildnummer...
...oder irgendein Bildhash oder was auch immer...
...dass man sich anzeigen lassen kann bei den Leuten, die das testen...
...dass du genau nachvollziehen kannst, welche ist es.
Das automatisch ist sinnvoll.
Aber ansonsten weiß ich jetzt nicht so genau, worauf...
...was du wissen willst.
Also musst du mal ein Tool bauen...
...das Git-Commits checkt und Versionsnummern taggt.
Also mit Conventional-Commit-Messages.
Naja gut...
...das kann man ja schon als Policy rausgeben...
...so nach dem Motto...
...wir wollen gescheite Git-Commit-Messages.
Ich bin da...
...ich bin da ein bisschen zwiegespalten...
...es zu sehr zu übertreiben...
...mit Anforderungen an...
...ermeintliche...
...Code-Qualität.
Ich erzähl euch mal ein Beispiel.
Also bei uns auf der Arbeit ist es so...
...dass wenn du...
...was an der Infrastruktur ändern willst...
...in der Cloud, das ist das meistens...
...über Terraform aufgebaut.
Und du hast...
...entweder mit deinem Admin-Account Rechte...
...das zu machen...
...wobei du dann mit Terraform Probleme hast...
...von deinem Notebook mit Admin-Account...
...und es funktioniert nicht gescheit.
Die einzige Möglichkeit gescheit Terraform Sachen...
...bei uns auf der Arbeit zu deployen ist...
...eine...
...CICD-Pipeline.
Und damit du dort...
...Terraform Sachen ausführen kannst...
...brauchst du...
...so viele nervige Schritte...
...die einfach nur Abfuck sind...
...und dafür sorgen, dass du so...
...extrem langsam bist bei allem.
Das fängt schon daran an...
...damit du...
...damit du was pushen kannst...
...sagen wir mal was ganz simples...
...sagen wir ich soll für die Entwicklungsumgebung...
...von Projekt XY...
...eine VM aufbauen...
...die irgendwas macht...
...VM-Funktion ist egal.
Also ist das normalerweise mit Terraform relativ einfach...
...du nimmst den Provider...
...also das Modul...
...von dem jeweiligen Cloud Provider...
...stellst ein ich will eine VM erstellen...
...mit Debian 32 GB RAM...
...so und so viele CPUs...
...netzwerk...
...easy...
...bei uns ist das so geregelt...
...man kann das witzigerweise...
...umgehen größtenteils deswegen...
...ja egal kommen wir gleich zu...
...naja zumindest...
...jetzt musst du erstmal ein Modul bauen...
...für diese Geschichte...
...dann brauchst du ein eigenes...
...GitLab Projekt...
...für die jeweilige...
...für das jeweilige Projekt...
...und für die jeweilige Umgebung...
...da musst du dort ein Terraform anlegen...
...das includen von deinem Modul für die VM...
...so und an jeder Stelle...
...hast du die bescheuertsten...
...Linting...
...und...
...Checker...
...also das in irgendeiner Pipeline gecheckt wird...
...dass das Valid Terraform ist...
...da habe ich ja nichts dagegen...
...das macht ja durchaus Sinn...
...das zu checken...
...aber die checken alles...
...da sind Checker mittlerweile drin...
...ich habe letztens ein Terraform Modul gebaut...
...das hatte 3 Zeilen Bash Script drin...
...und da ist irgendein Linter...
...für mein Bash Script losgelaufen...
...und hat dann gesagt...
...nicht mal so Dinge wie...
...Leerzeichen hinter Pipes...
...sondern das ich irgendwas vollkommen Valid mäßiges...
...nicht verwenden darf...
...z.B. ich hatte in irgendeinem...
...Bash Script...
...hatte ich sowas hier drin...
...da hatte ich sowas hier drin...
...sinngemäß hier...
...allo was ist mit meiner Shell los...
...the fuck...
...VM...
...da hatte ich sinngemäß sowas drin...
...while read...
...äh...
...irgendwie sowas hier in der Richtung hatte ich da drin...
...äh ne...
...uh...
...irgendwie sowas in der Richtung...
...und das hier hat er angemeckert...
...so nach dem Motto...
...while read darf nicht verwendet werden...
...warum darf while read nicht verwendet werden...
...man weiß es nicht...
...weil irgendein komischer Linter der Meinung ist...
...while read ist kein guter Bash Code...
...und das ist so abfuck mittlerweile...
...auch meine Terraform Module funktionieren teilweise...
...auf den höchsten Gründen nicht...
...weil es meint es erkennt irgendein Kommentarzeichen...
...ich hatte letztens...
...also in Terraform machst du Kommentare so...
...und nicht so...
...es geht aber beides...
...es ist beides welle Terraform...
...so...
...und ich hatte letztens irgendwo...
...irgendwie sowas drin stehen...
...blub blub...
...und da hat er gesagt...
...Kommentare sollen gefälligst...
...mit Raute gemacht werden...
...das ist so dämlich...
...also das ist so übertrieben teilweise...
...und da muss ich halt sagen...
...dadurch...
...wird die Code Qualität auch nicht besser...
...es wird sich einfach nur irgendwas gesucht...
...um das Ganze zu umgehen...
...so und was jetzt teilweise die Leute machen ist...
...die pushen einfach gar nicht mehr...
...über...
...die machen keinen Feature Branch mehr...
...und pushen dann den Feature Branch...
...und machen eine Merge Request...
...und lassen die Pipeline laufen...
...sondern die pushen einfach blind in Master...
...weil es dort die Checks nicht gibt...
...also das ist halt das Ding...
...wenn du es zu sehr übertreibst...
...mit automatisierten Gängelungen...
...dann suchen sich die Leute irgendwie einen Weg drum herum...
...das ist das gleiche...
...wie wenn du sagst Passwortrichtlinien...
...wenn du sagst Passwortrichtlinien...
...mindestens...
...16 Zeichen...
...Sonderzeichen, Underscore...
...Nummern groß...
...Kleinschreibung und sowas...
...theoretisch könnte man das alles schön machen...
...ja ja ist es halt nicht...
...wenn du so übertriebene Passwortrichtlinien hast...
...dann kommt dann sowas raus...
...123 ABC Underscore...
...ABC 123 und sowas...
...achso ja vielleicht noch...
...ne wobei Sonderzeichen haben wir ja...
...moment...
...sowas kommt dann raus...
...das ist wenn du zu viele Passwortrichtlinien hast...
...dann kommt dann sowas raus...
...123 123...
...ABC Underscore...
...ABC 123 123...
...das ist dann ein Passwort...
...die an Sicherheitsrichtlinien genügt, aber...
...trotzdem scheiße ist...
...und sicherlich...
...in irgendwelchen Passwort-Datenbanken schon drin steht...
...dasswegen also ich halte von...
...zu komplexen Passwortrichtlinien gar nix...
...jaja genau, das ist unter anderem...
...eines der Probleme, also ich halte von...
...zu komplizierten Passwortrichtlinien gar nix...
...die einzige Passwortrichtlinie...
...die ich tatsächlich echt für sinnig halte...
...ist einmal...
...wenn du sicherstellen willst das Passwort der rotiert wäre...
...das du sagst ey...
...nicht exakt das gleiche Passwort...
Okay. Logisch. Und eine Länge. Eine Länge finde ich sinnvoll, dass man sagt, mindestens sagen wir mal 20 Zeichen oder mindestens, man könnte sogar sagen 24 Zeichen oder was auch immer, aber dann sonst nix.
Ja. Weil die Länge ist ja letztendlich das Entscheidende bei einem Passwort.
Klar können Leute immer noch 24-stellige dumme Passwörter nehmen, aber unterm Strich glaube ich, es gibt weniger Stress und weniger Kack-Passwörter und mehr Usability, wenn man einfach nur eine Länge vorgibt.
Weil wenn man einfach nur eine Passwortlänge vorgibt, ja, Notizzeiten, natürlich, die Leute schreiben sich das dann auf.
Also zum Beispiel, was ein ganz gutes Passwort wäre, wenn du sagst, ey, mindestens 24 Stelle.
Dann würde ich sagen, das ist ein ganz gutes Passwort.
Dann würde ich sagen, hier, der, äh, komm, sogar, Großheim, der Twitch-Chat ist heute 5Head.
So. Das wäre ein ziemlich gutes Passwort.
Das hat 1, 2, 3, 4, 5...
Ey, keine Ahnung, ich hab mich verzählt, irgendwie 30 Zeichen oder sowas.
Bei Passwörtern auf jeden Fall.
Bei anderen Sachen vielleicht auch, aber bei Passwörtern kommt es mathematisch bewiesen auf die Länge an.
Hauptsächlich auf die Länge.
Ja, das wäre ein ziemlich gutes Passwort.
Es ist natürlich blöd, wenn ihr jetzt irgendwann auf die Idee kommt und das verwendet und dann sagt, ja, Moment, warum, der Max hat doch gesagt, das ist ein gutes Passwort.
Also Passwörter, die irgendwo schon mal im Klartext standen, sind nie gute Passwörter.
Deswegen könnte man auch sagen, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 ist das beste Passwort, weil es das weltweit verbreitetste Passwort ist.
Und alles, was besonders verbreitet ist, muss auch besonders gut sein.
Wir haben krasse Passwortregeln, das müssen wir alle 6 Monate ändern.
Das Passwort darf nicht 1.
Das müssen die letzten 32 Passwörter sein, Alter.
Jetzt wollen sie es aber wissen, Mann.
32 Passwörter, jetzt haben sie es aber echt.
Also, wir haben auf der Arbeit auch ein bisschen übertriebene Passwortregeln.
Und ich habe mich noch nicht auf ein System festgelegt, ob ich irgendwas hochzähle und sonst was.
Aber wahrscheinlich wird es darauf rauslaufen, ja.
So, dann lasst uns doch mal auf YouTube gucken, was wir hier Schönes haben.
Übrigens, ich muss heute Abend wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen, ich muss.
Muss ist jetzt natürlich ein bisschen, aber ich muss.
Das ist ein bisschen übertrieben, ne.
Ich werde heute Abend vielleicht noch ein bisschen Darkstream, weil es gibt gerade PvP-Event und ich werde heute eben den ganzen Tag spielen.
Hallo?
Muss mal kurz gucken, wie es steht.
Muss mal kurz gucken, wie steht es denn aktuell, wie.
Muss eingeloggt sein, ja.
Moment, easy, easy.
Ich bin doch im Firefox hier eingeloggt.
Sekunde, Sekunde.
Ich bin doch im Firefox eingeloggt.
Okay.
Ja.
Wie steht es denn aktuell?
Wie steht es aktuell gerade?
Oh.
Wir sind nur noch 600 Punkte hintendran.
Nice.
Da wären wir vielleicht doch nicht letzter.
Ja, da muss ich nach dem Stream gleich wieder PvP grinden.
Ist das hier live?
Nein, das ist Recorded Stream.
So, was ist das hier?
Jetzt gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Ich gucke mir doch jetzt keine 30 Minuten Pentium 3 an.
Ein bisschen zu viel ist gut, ne.
Was können wir uns denn hier angucken?
Okay.
Was erfolgreiche Programmierer tun und du wahrscheinlich nicht.
Boah, easy, kommt drauf an.
Äh, Antivirus-Tierlist.
Oh nein, please.
Please.
Oh ne, das wird was.
Da muss ich flamen, wenn ich das gucke.
Wobei, ganz ehrlich, ich hab mir letztens ja schon mal ein Tierlist-Video von dem Kerl angeguckt.
Und ich muss sagen, ich bin erstaunlich d'accord gegangen, wie man so schön sagt, mit seiner Tierlist.
Das war ne Tierlist zu, ich glaube, Linux, ne, wir haben zwei Sachen angeguckt.
Linux-Desktop-Environments und Linux-Distros.
Und ich konnte seine Sache zumindest nachvollziehen oftmals.
Und gerade bei Distros waren wir uns erstaunlich einig, ja.
Nur eine Sache hat da drinne stehen, die fand ich total bescheuert.
Aber gut, das ist alles, was ich sage, ja.
Aber.
Die Antivirus-Tierlist.
Okay, das Video ist nur 10 Minuten lang, das können wir uns schnell angucken.
Wobei, ihr wisst, wenn ich 10 Minuten Videos gucke, dann ist gleich 13 Uhr.
Mal gucken, wie schnell wir sind mit dem 10 Minuten Video.
Ich könnte ja ein bisschen was skippen.
Also, im Prinzip realistisch betrachtet, ne, die einzige Antivirus-Sache, die man aktuell verwenden sollte,
sprich, kann's natürlich jeder machen, wie er will,
ist Windows Defender.
Oder, wie heißt das Ding jetzt eigentlich korrekt?
Microsoft Advanced Threat Protection, oder so.
Windows Defender.
Kommt mit Windows mit, fängt so die gröbsten Sachen ab und fuckt dein System nicht.
So. Das ist eigentlich ganz okay.
Das hab sogar ich aktiviert.
Aber selbst das, nur mal, nur mal so, bevor man das Video jetzt anguckt,
selbst das ist nicht ganz ohne, weil auch der Windows Defender hatte schon Sicherheitslücken,
die das System angreifbarer gemacht haben.
Nicht hätten, haben.
Nachweislich angreifbar-
Gibt's nämlich Probleme!
Nachweislich angreifbarer gemacht haben,
als ohne Virenscanner.
Das ist auch so ein Ding, was man immer bei der ganzen,
bei dem ganzen Security-Software-Wahn vergisst,
dem da viele verfallen.
Grade früher, heute noch einige Unternehmen,
jede Software, die man hat,
sorgt potenziell für Probleme,
und sorgt potenziell auch für weitere Sicherheitsprobleme.
Also nicht nur für Usability, Anwendungs-, Abfugsachen, sondern auch für Sicherheitsprobleme.
Also nicht nur für Usability, Anwendungs-, Abfugsachen, sondern auch für Sicherheitsprobleme. Also nicht nur für Usability, Anwendungs-, Abfugsachen, sondern auch für Sicherheitsprobleme.
probleme also alles was da ist kann probleme machen deswegen ist ja auch das
beste auf einem linux server wenn man einfach nur die ports offen hat mit
diensten die man auch exposen will dann brauchst du keine firewall da brauchst
du keine regeln dass das nicht immer geht ist mir auch klar ja aber wenn man
die ports wenn man nur die ports offen hat am public interface die man auch
exposen will dann brauchst du so gut wie keine irgendwie die großartig
netzwerktechnik großartige gedanken zu machen
es sei denn die anwendung die dahinter läuft ist selber nicht sicher genug dass
man sie ins internet hängen will einmal der sache nicht traut dann muss man auch
in reverse proxy davor machen mit authentifizierung oder sowas aber
prinzipiell ist was nicht da ist oder nicht offen ist oder nicht vorhanden ist
kann auch keine probleme machen ist bei datenschutz ähnlich oder bei passwörter
in der cloud wenn eure passwörter erst gar nicht in der cloud sind bei
irgendwem anbieter dann können die auch nicht geliebt werden wenn ihr euch
überall nur mit fakedaten anmeldet dann müsst ihr nicht müsst ihr nicht morgen
damit rechnen dass eure persönlichen daten irgendwo in einem liegt rinne
auftauchen alles was nicht da ist kann keine probleme machen
so dann gucken wir uns das ganze mal an
antivirus tierlist also aus meiner sicht gibt es also für windows weil für andere
Systeme ist das eh meistens eh nicht
sonderlich sinnvoll, aber für Windows
ist S-Tier Windows Defender,
ich würde nur nicht mal sagen S-Tier, selbst Windows
Defender ist nicht unhinterfragt
immer geilst, überhaupt
beste für alles
und das, was man immer
ungefragt machen sollte.
Ich würde sagen, es gibt kein S-Tier Antivirus,
es gibt A-Tier Antivirus,
das ist der Windows Defender und der Rest
kommt in, ja was auch immer, D-Tier
nicht benutzen.
Gibt es eigentlich schon ein NordVPN
Antivirus mittlerweile?
Du musst werbe-danisch für den Sub.
Einen Rott.
Reden wir jetzt von Windows Desktop oder was
anderem? Also man, es gibt ja
es gibt ja durchaus legit
Anwendungsfälle für
Virenscanner, so ist das nicht.
Zum Beispiel ein
Corporate File Share oder sowas,
also irgendein Enterprise Business
File Share auf der Arbeit.
Das muss noch nicht mal ein
Windows File Share sein.
Das kann auch eine Linux mit einem Samba drauf sein,
wo die Leute Dateien draufschieben können.
Da ab und zu mal einen Virenscan laufen
zu lassen, ist durchaus sinnvoll.
Ich sage nicht, dass Virenscanner allgemein
komplett useless sind.
Gibt es eigentlich noch
Moment,
Sekunde. Gibt es eigentlich noch
Klamm AV oder Virenscanner?
Wie das heißt? Das war mal so ein Open Source
kostenloser Virenscanner
für Linux.
AV.
Der nie super super krasse Detection
Rates hatte.
Ach, das gehört jetzt zu Cisco
oder zu Zisco, wie das manche Leute
aussprechen.
Moment, ist das jetzt written in Rust?
Ach nee, es gibt, es hat nur Rust Bindings.
Es hat nur Rust Bindings.
Ich hätte schon gedacht, man.
Moment.
Ja, das hat nur Rust Bindings.
Okay, dann schauen wir mal.
Ups.
I've done IT for about 20 years.
Es kann leider schon ein bisschen was skippen.
Got a hundred or so different businesses.
So I can and gonna really it's the last thing.
Only care to touch on that.
It'll show me the antivirus.
We'll send her be good with.
Okay, was ist das?
Avira, oder?
Antiviruses here.
Now we'll start off with.
Avira.
Let's go like Avira.
We'll go down.
Avira.
Middle.
This used to be pretty good back when free
antivirus was kind of.
Richtig, richtig.
Ich habe früher auch immer Avira verwendet.
So das letzte Mal so vor 15 Jahren oder so.
Needed but with Windows Defender being in the pretty good category,
I would say this is no longer.
Hey, wenn der am Ende das genauso macht, wie ich vorgeschlagen habe,
es nur Windows Defender ist ATS Tier ist nichts und der Rest ist dann.
Dann fände ich das sehr Poggers.
Really needed.
There's no point in downloading a lot of free antivirus.
One.
Windows Defender.
There's no point in downloading a lot of free antivirus.
Windows Defender pretty much takes care of everything for you.
So when we look at these, there's a couple of different things and many people don't know this,
but AVG used to be good.
Hab ich nie verwendet.
Hat das jemand mal benutzt?
Same with Avast.
They're actually the same company.
They got.
Ich kenne, ich kenne die Logos gar nicht mehr.
Ist das Bitdefender hier unten, Leute?
Ist das Bitdefender das einzige, was mir einfällt?
Ich kenne die.
Okay, das ist Norton.
Äh, Norton, Norton gewesen, oder?
Ich kenne den Rest nicht mehr.
Da sieht man mal, wie unbedeutend Virenscanner geworden sind, dass ich die Logos gar nicht
mehr kenne.
Das ist Kaspersky.
B2CS.
Aha, siehste?
Ja, das ist tatsächlich ein Fall, wo es sinnvoll ist, einen Antivirus-Anbieter zu haben.
Ja, aber mir ging es ja hauptsächlich um Windows-Desktop-Systeme, so private Windows-Desktop-Systeme.
F-Secure das erste System.
Ich kenne.
Was sind das?
Hinten sieht aus wie wirklich irgendwie NordVPN oder so.
Egal, schauen wir weiter.
Wo ist denn, wo ist denn eigentlich McAfee hin?
Gibt's das noch?
Ist es das?
Äh.
Ja, wie soll man sagen, so Geschichte, wem es gehört.
Das gehörte ja gefühlt auch schon irgendwie acht verschiedenen Eigentümern.
Wem gehörten das eigentlich gerade?
Wem gehörten das eigentlich aktuell?
Es war mal Symantec oder so zwischenzeitlich.
Und was ist es jetzt?
Wem gehört das jetzt?
Trend Micro.
Äh, Symantec, ist es immer noch?
Ach, Gen Digital heißen die jetzt.
Gen Digital, das ist so weird.
Also das hat auch schon zig Dinger durchgemacht.
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern, ja.
An diesen Krempel kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Erinnert sich noch jemand an Norton Internet Security Suite?
Kennt das noch jemand?
Norton Internet Security.
Ja, genau.
Wo ist das Screenshot?
Genau, ja, ja.
Ja, oh Mann.
Das waren noch Zeiten, wo man sich mit seinem DSL-Modem direkt an das Internet angestöpselt hat.
Also, das werden vielleicht die wenigsten noch kennen.
Aber das waren Zeiten, da hatte man keinen Router mit NAT davor.
Man hat das DSL-Modem.
Am Anfang von DSL.
Man hat das DSL-Modem direkt an die Netzwerkkarte vom PC angeschlossen und sich dort eingewählt.
Das heißt, der PC selbst hatte eine Public Internet IP.
Und ihr könnt euch jetzt überlegen, was für eine doofe Idee es ist,
einen Windows, ja, äh, XP-Rechner, war es wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil damals,
ein Windows XP-Rechner, erste Generation, ohne irgendwas, ungeschützt mit einer Public IP,
ins Internet zu stellen.
Da gab es ja damals sogar so Untersuchungen, so nach dem Motto,
wie lang dauert es, bis ein frisch installierter, ins Internet gestellter PC infiziert ist.
Das hat am Ende irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 25 Sekunden gedauert oder so.
25 Sekunden.
Also, das konntest du komplett, konntest du komplett knicken.
Ja.
Und da hast du so Kram gebraucht.
Damals gab es das hier.
Und was ich damals hatte bei mir auf dem Rechner,
äh, gibt es das noch?
Gibt es noch Zone-Alarm?
Das ist total aus der Mode gekommen.
Okay, das gibt es sogar noch.
Guck mal, das gibt es noch.
Ach, Checkpoint ist das jetzt, okay.
Zone-Alarm, ja.
Warte mal hier.
Zone-Alarm Windows XP.
Für alle.
Das kennen die einen oder anderen auch.
Mal gucken, für die.
Installing Zone-Alarm.
V12.
Ja.
Ich hoffe, man sieht das Interface gleich auch noch.
Damals war es schon Checkpoint.
Ja.
Genau, ja.
Aber, das sah, das, das, das, das, was ich, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Moment.
Lass uns die älteren Sachen angucken.
Okay, ja, gibt es, gibt es keine.
Ja, zumindest, das, das war damals.
Eines, ja, so sah das aus, so gelb.
Genau, ja, ja, ja, genau, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Das, das war schon das Neue.
Das war schon das Neue.
Das war schon das Neue Interface.
Das so gelb mit dem Stop-Button und sowas.
Genau, Zone-Alarm.
So sah das damals aus.
Da konntest du auch Firewall-Regeln machen und sowas.
Und du wurdest, du wurdest, genau.
Du wurdest immer, wenn du irgendein neues Programm gestartet hast,
was versucht hat, aufs Internet zuzugreifen,
wurdest du immer gefragt, so,
möchtest du das zulassen, dass dieses Programm aufs Internet zugreift?
Ehrlich gesagt, war dieser Schutz damals schon für den Arsch.
Das Einzige, wofür diese Firewalls gut waren,
aber was die 0815-Noot-Benutzer,
ich, mich eingeschlossen damals, zumindest am Anfang,
nicht gecheckt haben, ist,
diese Firewalls sind nicht unbedingt gut da drin,
ausgehenden Traffic zu blockieren.
Diese Firewalls sind ganz nützlich da drin,
ungefragt eingehenden Traffic zu blockieren.
Das ist das Problem, was du damals mit frischen Windows-Installationen im Internet hattest.
Da war irgendwelche, irgendwelche, ähm,
RPC-Ports, hier, Port 445 und sowas,
offen,
wo du sofort infiziert warst drüber.
Die Firewalls waren gut da drin,
aber nicht dafür, einfach jeglichen eingehenden Traffic zu blocken.
Übrigens, dieses Desaster,
was Windows XP zu Release da hatte,
mit diesen Anfälligkeiten,
das war ja auch der Grund, warum Microsoft damals Windows XP,
äh, wie ist das, Service Pack 2, glaube ich, rausgebracht hat.
Windows XP Service Pack 2 war ja ein mehr oder weniger neues Windows.
Da kamen auch sehr viele Sachen dazu, zum ersten Mal,
wie beispielsweise diese, die Windows Firewall und sowas.
Ja, so sah, so sah Sound-Alarm damals aus.
Incoming NetBIOS is blocked.
Das wäre heute überhaupt kein Problem,
das wieder öffentlich ins Internet zu stellen,
weil ich glaube, das probiert heutzutage kein Hacker mehr, ein Attacker mehr,
da irgendwas über NetBIOS zu machen, äh.
Ja, gut.
Gut, komm, komm, komm, komm mal zurück zum, zum eigentlichen,
zum eigentlichen.
Aber Sound-Alarm,
auch so ein Ding damals.
What's up with that?
And, and when you look at
any other like best one, uh, they're always at the top here.
That's because they pay the highest.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, also bei diesen Seiten muss man sich ja auch nicht wundern,
dass da, also, das sind so Top-Listen, da würde ich nichts drauf geben.
Rips, I think some of the rips are going up as high as 50%.
So if you pay $100 to them, your favorite influencer just got a $50 kickback.
Uh, so that's kind of a fun one, but they are awful antiviruses.
Their detection rates, again, on par with Windows Defender, but you're paying through
the nose.
Also you have a lot of lock in or vendor lock in with these guys because they offer a suite of products.
Don't ever bundle in like a password.
Ich hatte auf dem Rechner, als ich mal vor einem Jahr oder so bei meinem Vater am Rechner war, der hatte sich auch, ich glaube, AVG oder sowas installiert und du konntest den Scheiß gar nicht richtig mehr deinstallieren.
Da musste ich auf meinem Handy tatsächlich googeln, how to remove AVG antivirus, ich glaube, AVG war das.
How to remove?
Da musstest du quasi,
abgesicherter Modus starten, um das dann zu löschen.
So ein Bullshit, Alter.
Ich glaube, es war AVG.
Das war AVG.
Also ich habe natürlich mit der V republic
quellen.
Also ich habe nicht.
Das ist eigentlich der einzige.
Ist die Ressourcen.
Gut.
Ja.
Wenn ich sage ich, dass ich in einem Alter, wo ich das Video noch nie gesehen habe, habe ich, die Verpackung in der Manhalle bis heute noch nicht misser.
Ich bin values.
Ich weiß nicht.
der Meinung ist, die wollen
einen Samba-Falscher regelmäßig
scannen und wollen dafür unbedingt
sich bei den Comrades
eine Kaspersky-Lizenz kaufen. Ja,
Go for it, meinetwegen.
Was ist das?
Viper?
Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Was ist das?
Kennt ihr das?
Das ist Viper-Antivirus.
Aber warum?
Ich fand sie okay,
aber ihre Detektionsrate
war damals wirklich schlecht.
Und im Allgemeinen nicht etwas,
was ich empfehlen würde.
Ich denke, Windows Defender
wäre vielleicht noch besser als sie.
Das ist mein Thought-Prozess.
Gehen wir zu Bitdefender.
Ich würde es in die gute Kategorie nehmen.
Sie haben einen freien Modell,
einen freien Antivirus.
Es ist auf jeden Fall
mit Bitdefender in Ordnung.
Ich würde es nicht besser nennen.
Ich würde es eher in die Mitte schieben.
Weil ich Bitdefender mag,
habe ich nichts Schlechtes zu sagen.
Aber ich habe auch nicht viel
Großartiges zu sagen.
Ich würde es in die A-Kategorie nehmen.
ESET hat einen Marktführer.
Sonst war es nicht Nod32.
In der heutigen Zeit.
Das packt ja nicht wirklich in Est hier, oder?
Not Antivirus.
Ja, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Tatsächlich, das gab es früher auch.
Ich denke, es wurde in den letzten 80ern
immer noch ein sehr gutes Antivirus.
Ich habe es gesehen, dass es ein bisschen schwerer wird.
Aber ich denke, dass ihre Detektionsrate
ein bisschen besser ist als in Bitdefender.
Aber ich weiß es nicht.
Ich gehe ein bisschen zurück und forth.
Würde ich Geld dafür bezahlen,
über Bitdefender?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ehrlich gesagt, für mich sind Bitdefender
in der Regel gut genug,
wenn man es mit ESET vergleicht.
Kaspersky,
ihre Detektionsrate sind eigentlich in der S-Tier.
Ja, aber ECOS, da kannst du auch einfach
Windows Defender eingeschaltet lassen.
Sie haben eine großartige Detektion,
aber es ist super neugierig.
Und es ist eine russisch basierte Firma.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich lasse es einfach in einer ziemlich guten Kategorie.
Ganz ehrlich, wenn du bei der Oma nicht gucken willst,
dann gibt der Oma irgendeinen Linux mit einem Browser drauf.
Damit kommt die Oma auch klar.
Die Oma will ja nichts machen.
Sie hat einen guten freien...
Und das Wichtigste, genau, Janu, ich wollte es gerade sagen.
Das Wichtigste ist tatsächlich
irgendein halbwegs sicher eingestellter Browser.
Früher war es NoScript.
NoScript in der Form gibt es, glaube ich, nicht mehr.
Seit Firefox damals schon die ganzen Plugin-APIs abgeschaltet hat,
gibt es NoScript in der alten Form nicht mehr.
Aber uBlock ist schon mal was ganz Praktisches.
Weil es Defender verlängert und du nur Kaspersky Cloud-frei hast.
Also nicht zu schlecht.
Malwarebytes, du weißt, viele Leute, die viele Virus-Virus entfernt haben...
Was? Ach, Malwarebytes, das gibt es auch noch.
Die hatten doch früher, wie hieß das denn?
Gab es nicht diesen Trojaner-Scanner früher von Malwarebytes?
Wie hieß das Ding?
Weiß das noch jemand?
Das ist das, wo die Leute früher immer gesagt haben,
lass mal einen Scan von Malwarebytes.
Lass mal einen Scan von Malwarebytes.
Malwarebytes oder sowas laufen und dann poste den Report hier.
Anti-Malwarebytes, war das das?
Ja, kann sein.
Nee, nee, nicht.
Adware-Cleaner, nee.
Same goes for Sophos.
Ach, die gibt es ja auch noch.
Bei Sophos denke ich immer an irgendwelche superteuren Appliance-Dinger.
Don't like their anti-Virus, but their scan is probably one of the most in-depth scans on the net.
And I really love mixing in them when scanning for viruses.
And they have a great free scan.
By the way, die letzten zwei Logos habe ich noch nie im Leben gesehen, was ist das?
...are out on the market, so Sophos really gets a good vote for me.
WebRoot, you know, I've talked about it a lot.
Kenne ich nicht.
WebRoot?
...talked about it in the past.
I really like WebRoot.
Their detection rates are actually less than a lot of these A-Tier ones, but their Secure
Anywhere Business Suite I've actually used for, you know, probably five or six years
in some client sites.
Very minimal, very good, but I only use the anti-Virus and I also disable many of its
advanced features, such as an exploit that came out with WebRoot, Scare Anywhere, where
I think some people...
WebRoot habe ich noch nie gehört.
...were exploiting.
...were exploiting aspect of it.
So, be cautious with this if you go that route, but I do love its central management console,
very lightweight, very easy to manage, and honestly has really good detection rates.
In the same...
Ja, okay, aber wenn man das jetzt aus Windows, aus Business-Sicht beurteilt, ja, dann ist
das ja eh wieder was komplett anderes.
...realm, Trend Micro used to be really good, you know, 10, 15 years ago.
I used them all the time, but...
Naja.
...slowly they kind of just...
...gott.
Naja, ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, ne.
Also ich würde mir auf meinem Desktop nichts anderes interessieren als, was heißt installieren,
nichts anderes zusätzlich drauf machen als Windows Defender und fertig.
Kaputt durch Unterforderungen.
Bore out.
Also, da kann man Abhilfe schaffen.
Handy raus, Discord auf, Reddit, Twitch.
Aber, ja, im Prinzip ist es sicherlich kacke.
Wenn du 8 Stunden da sitzt und nicht langweilst.
Also wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was ich mir ein Kombination, was ich mir richtig kacke vorstelle?
Wenn du dich langweil...
Also die Kombination aus Langeweile, aber so tun müssen als ob.
So nach dem Motto, ich kann nicht einfach öffentlich da sitzen und den ganzen Tag Twitch gucken,
so nach dem Motto, ich hab nix zu tun, sondern immer wenn jemand ins Büro reinkommt, schnell
Twitch schließen müssen und dann irgendwie...
Aha, aha, aha, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Ja, ja, okay, und dann geht der Typ raus, aber Twitch wieder auf.
Ja, das ist abfuck, da hätte ich keinen Bock drauf.
Wenn ich lange genug gemeckert hätte, dass ich nix zu tun hab und mein Chef dann sagt,
ja gut, können wir auch nix machen, dann würde ich halt einfach öffentlich Twitch gucken.
Okay, lass mal kommen.
Aber ich guck mir jetzt keine, ich guck mir jetzt keine 28 Minuten Doku an.
Bei mir dauert das wieder 3 Stunden.
Was ist das denn hier?
Habt ihr schon mal einen so großen PC gesehen?
Es ist ein Doppelt.
Es ist ein Socket, Doppelt, wie nennt sich das?
Dual Socket Xeon System, so wie es aussieht.
Von, tja, ja, steht ja hier, frühen 2000ern.
Super fettes Ding.
Von der Farbe her ein bisschen wie alte Sun-Systeme.
Die waren ja auch...
Also eine Sache muss man ja mal den alten Servern wirklich zugute halten.
Auch wenn ich mir hier...
Oh, war das SCSI-Festplatten, Leute?
Das ist ja richtig...
Ja, oder?
Oder?
Ja.
Für das 68-Polige Ultra-SCSI.
Ja, ja, ja, das SCSI.
Okay, das ist richtig alt.
Das ist wirklich aus den frühen 2000ern.
Also eins muss man ja sagen, was die Hardware damals hatte, ist,
das war wirklich richtig robust.
Also damit konntest du...
Gut, Leute, erschlagen kannst du mit aktueller Hardware, wenn es drauf ankommt, auch noch.
Aber die war so robust, damit...
Die kannst du aus dem Flieger werfen fast schon, ja.
Und du kannst danach immer noch was recoveren davon.
Die waren super robust, auch schwer, die Dinger.
Ah, der gute...
Gute alte Parallel-Port für den Drucker.
Es gibt heute noch Mainboards, die haben den.
Ich sehe immer mal wieder, gerade günstige, billige Mainboards, die haben den.
Vier maximal.
Für was? Ich weiß es nicht, für was.
Was?
Hat noch irgendjemand einen Drucker, der über Parallel-Port angeschlossen wird, Leute?
Und selbst wenn, da gibt es doch garantiert Adapter für...
Guck mal, USB-to-Parallel-Adapter.
Ja.
Guck mal, das ist sogar USB, auf dem die komischen Druckeranschluss da...
Ah, Nadeldrucker in Arztpraxen, okay.
Ja, aber dann würde ich auch einen USB...
Dann würde ich auch so einen USB auf Parallel verwenden.
Braucht es nicht.
Dann braucht es das Mainboard nicht mehr.
Aber man sieht damals auch schon drei Netzwerkeanschlüsse.
Ich vermute, wenn das ein Serversystem ist, dass einer der Netzwerkeanschlüsse die Konsole ist.
Vermutlich die hier...
Ne, Moment, das ist...
Sind das SFP-Stecker?
Leute, sind das...
Was ist das da unten?
Sind das SFP-Stecker?
Was ist denn das?
Was sind das überhaupt?
Ich erkenne das nicht.
Das sind Aeon 45, wirklich?
Die sehen so flach aus.
Aber wenn das zwei Aeon 45 sind, dann ist das wahrscheinlich die Konsole hier oben, auch wo die Tastatur ist.
So einen Nadeldrucker könnte man doch zur Tätowiermaschine umbauen.
Da habe ich mir noch keine Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Und Nadeldrucker sind auch was?
Wo ich ehrlich gesagt gar keine Ahnung habe, wie die genau funktionieren.
Stimmt, hier hast du zwei LEDs dran.
Ja.
Ja, aber das finde ich nice, dass der alte Hardware so super robust ist.
Man sieht auch schon hier damals doppeltes Netzteil möglich.
Hat er jetzt nicht.
Wundert mich.
Aber auch schon Dual-Netzteile.
Das ist ja heute auch noch Standard bei Servern.
Was haben wir denn hier sonst drin?
Okay, zwei unterschiedliche Lüfter?
Das scheint mir so...
Jetzt hat da schon einer ein bisschen dran rumgebaut.
Da hat er doch noch ein bisschen...
Also das ist doch bestimmt nicht Default, oder?
Zwei unterschiedliche Lüfter auf dem CPU.
Das werden die schon die zwei gleichen CPUs sein.
Das ist ein Dual-Socketboard.
Jede Menge RAM-Riegel.
Da haben wir noch jede Menge Chipsatz-Dinger.
Und was haben wir hier?
PCI.
Dreimal.
Und das da unten könnte fast noch ein ISA-Slot oder sowas sein.
So sieht der PC von innen aus.
Wenn die LEDs abgezogen sind, weil das ist irgendwie jetzt irgendwie aus der Halbdauer raus.
Muss ich das mal zeigen.
Stimmt, das ist ein Extended-PCI-Port.
Das ist kein normaler PCI-Port.
Da ist ein PC, der ist gefühlt...
Oh, wobei...
Muss ich das mal zeigen.
Der ist ein bisschen hier hinten ein bisschen lang für einen normalen PCI-Port, richtig?
Da sieht der PC zu unförmig aus.
Wobei, ich kann mich nicht mal richtig dran erinnern, wie genau PCI...
Ja, genau.
PCI war da hinten auch noch so...
So einen kurzen.
Was ist das?
Server-ASMA hier, Leute.
Und hier unten...
Hört mal.
Server-ASMA.
...ist ein normaler PCI-Slot und ein...
Server-Cringle-Sounds.
ASMA.
...SMDC-Connector.
Wenn jemand weiß, was dieser SMDC-Connector...
SMDC-Connector habe ich noch nie gehört.
...habe ich noch nie gehört.
Hier hinten sehen wir halt noch den...
IDE.
...von diesem Mainboard.
Also generell, dieses Mainboard ist einfach wahnsinnig gigantisch.
Hier in der Hand zum Vergleich.
Ich hole mal kurz ein normales ATX-Mainboard.
Ein normales Full-Sized-ATX-Board.
Wenn ich das jetzt hier so reinlege, sehen wir...
Das ist richtig groß.
Gut, aber das war die Technik von damals.
Und es war ein Dual-Sockel.
Und es war ein Server-Board, wo noch irgendwie eine Konsole und alles drauf ist.
Server-Boards sind heute auch noch ein bisschen größer.
Aber die hatten wir damals schon größer, ja.
Aber es ist...
...put gewesen.
Ach, deswegen einen Lüfter getauscht.
Sieben.
Netzteil.
Oh.
Pass mal auf.
Hört ihr? Hört ihr? Den...
Die meisten Server drehen ja tatsächlich ein bisschen runter, nachdem sie einmal gepostet haben.
Alter, was hat der denn da für Ultra-Oldschool-Dinger im Hintergrund am Start?
Und die Lautstärke im Raum hat sich schon erhöht.
Das sieht aus wie so ein Ding, wo der Bademeister...
...seine Durchsagen drüber macht.
Ich lasse das jetzt mal umgeschnitten, wie lange der zum Booten braucht.
Ja, das...
...das dauert.
Man muss sagen, es gibt heute auch noch Server, die richtig eklig langsam booten.
Also, der für mich, der Worst Offender, sozusagen, was Bootzeiten angeht, waren...
...Plates Center, Plates...
...HS, glaube ich, 23?
Oder...
...HS 22, HS 21?
Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr genau.
Ich glaube, HS 22 zu Release.
Die Dinger haben ohne Scheiß 5, das ist kein Witz, 5 Minuten gebootet.
Ja.
Kennt ihr noch jemand?
Die Teile, die mit der Release-Firmware-Version.
Die haben so ewig gebootet.
Das war ein...
Ey, das war so abartig.
Gerade, ich kann mich noch daran erinnern, wir hatten ein paar Linux-Kisten darauf laufen.
Und...
...wenn da halt wirklich mal was war...
...musstest du halt auch mal in Bootmanager.
Und du musstest dem Ding 5 Minuten zugucken, beim Booten, dass du nicht den Moment verpasst hast, wann du im Crap eine Taste drücken musstest, um dann die Bootline zu editieren.
Warum er das stehen hat, weiß ich auch nicht.
Hab mich aber auch schon gewundert, was da rumsteht.
Das waren wirklich die Abarten, also die Boots, das war echt jenseits von allem, die Bootzeiten.
Post, big screen.
Also, die booten richtig langsam, die Dinger.
Gerade, wenn die noch jede Menge Onboard-Sachen haben.
In der Zeit wäre ein aktueller Rechner schon dreimal hochgefahren.
Ja.
Ein aktueller Server vielleicht nullmal.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber...
...das dauert ewig.
Das dauert wirklich ewig, das Zeug.
Der checkt jetzt jeden einzelnen RAM-Slot und so...
Das gibt's nicht schon, dass er einen Ami-BIOS hat.
Windows Server...
Und schon...
Wie kann man so ein altes Ding so versauen, Leute?
Warum ist da nicht wenigstens ein Debian?
Ja, was war denn da so aktuell?
Woody oder sowas?
Was war denn so um die Zeit, um die Zeit aktuell, man?
Keine Ahnung.
Edge?
Woody, Woody wahrscheinlich, ja?
Irgendein olles Debian oder so drauf sein.
Booten wir in Windows Server 2003.
Also, die Bootzeiten gingen so.
Also, die Bootzeiten gingen noch voll klar bis jetzt.
Also, das Playcenter wär damals nicht über das Raid-Initialisieren raus...
...das HS22 mit Release...
...wär nicht über Raid-Initialisieren raus gewesen.
Und irgendwie mag mein Monitor die Auflösung nicht.
Ja, das wird sich gleich wieder einpendeln.
Aber Windows booten ist jetzt auch nicht das Allerschnellste gerade.
Wenn ich Quickboot oder Quietboot aktiviert hab, haben wir jetzt nicht die einzelne Initialisierung der Raid-Controller gesehen, sondern...
...haben nur den Postscreen gesehen und das wurde jetzt alles schon im Hintergrund gemacht.
Quick, Quickboot.
Und deswegen geht das jetzt etwas schneller.
Dauert natürlich noch immer noch ewig.
Drücken Sie STRG-ALT entfernt, um sich anzumelden, dann machen wir das mal.
Ja.
Also, ich hab ja so ein Herz für so alte Hardware.
Ich mein, ich bräuchte sie daheim nicht, ich würd's auch nicht verwenden, aber...
...ich guck mir sowas gerne an und wenn ich irgendwo mal was sehen würde, würd ich auch mal reingucken.
Aber haben will ich sie nicht, weil was willst du damit?
Du kannst damit nix mehr machen und der Nostalgie-Faktor ist ja dann auch recht schnell erschöpft, ja?
Aber ich hab da irgendwie ein Herz für alte Hardware.
Genauso, wenn's um alte Sachen geht, für Nagios, was Monitoring-Systeme angeht.
Ich mag Nagios. Niemand mag Nagios, aber ich mag Nagios noch.
Benutz es nicht, aber ich mag's noch.
Keine.
Dieses hässliche Ding gibt es immer noch in aktuellen Windows-Server-Versionen.
Erinnert ihr euch noch dran?
Wie sehr ich mich gequält habe...
...mit...
...Windows-Server?
Ja.
Erinnert ihr euch noch dran, wie sehr ich mich mit diesem Shit gequält habe?
So ein Schrott, Alter.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich mich mit Windows-Server auseinandersetzen muss, muss ich kotzen, Alter.
Das ist so...
...verplanter, wirrer Scheiß.
Ich kann nicht verstehen, wie irgendjemand freiwillig Windows-Server verwendet.
Und wir sind...
Das ging jetzt natürlich schneller, als ich's in Erinnerung hatte bei dem.
Gut, dann war das der HP-Server, der so lange gebraucht wird.
Warum haben wir kein Hintergrundbild?
Was ist da drauf?
7-Zip!
Ey, das ist ja schon relativ aktuell, das Zeug, ja?
Desktop...
Xeon...
...Prestonia...
...ja...
...mit zwei Kernen...
Das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Also, ich mein, das ist uralt, ja?
Aber das ist für die damalige Zeit...
...das ist GAR nicht so schlecht!
Das ist ein Dual-Core-Xeon, das heißt, es hat zwei CPUs?
Nee.
Das stimmt doch überhaupt nicht.
Da steht doch eindeutig ein Core nur da.
Wo steht... wo... wo... wo...
Mit zwei Kernen?
Nee.
Nicht zwei Kernen.
Ein Kern.
Zwei... zwei...
Das sind zwei CPUs, mit jeweils...
MX-Support, SSE-Support, SSE-Support.
Ja.
Das sind... genau, das ist... das... das war noch pre...
... ähm, pre-Multi... Multicore-CPU.
Ja, ja.
Das... das hier ist...
Das ist aber nicht...
Eine... das ist die erste CPU und die zweite.
Das heißt, die CPU gibt's nur einen Kern pro CPU.
Waterlider, danke schön für den Sub.
Okay, dann ist es doch wirklich Schrott.
Weil, ich mein, vier Kerne wären immer noch... immer noch irgendwie, ne?
Ja, das... das wird's.
Ich mein, man darf nicht... man darf's nicht unterschätzen.
Das war damals absolut High-End-Shit, das Ding.
Und wie viel Rahmen haben wir?
Wie viel Rahmen haben wir?
Haben wir insgesamt...
Äh, was ist das? 32...
Ich würde ja sagen 32 Gig.
Aber das Ding ist so alt...
Vielleicht sind's auch nur 3 Gig.
Drei Gigabyte, oder?
Ja, ich bin mir auch nicht sicher.
Was ist das denn? Was ist das denn?
Ich hab auch keine Ahnung.
Ich... ich würde auch sagen 3 Gigabyte.
Ich würde auch sagen 3, aber...
Drei Gigabyte, oder?
Ja, bin mir auch nicht ganz sicher.
Und wenn wir jetzt den Windows Explorer öffnen...
...sehen wir hier auch...
...HP-SCSI-RAID 5...
...das sind hier vorne...
Mit wie viel... mit wie viel Gigabyte? Man sieht's hier nebenbei.
...HP-SCSI-RAID 5...
Chat, 136 Gig, kann das sein?
136 Gig?
Das ist richtig, das...
Ey, ein 136 Gig...
...SCSI-RAID 5...
...also sprich, ähm, mindestens... mindestens 3 Platten?
Das war auch schon... also...
...nicht billig!
Das sind hier vorne...
...diese Platten...
Ja, 3!
...und da haben wir hier insgesamt...
...100...
...136 Gigabyte...
...das heißt...
Also das Ding hatte wirklich Wumms für die damalige Zeit!
3... 3...
Das dürfte... dürfte tatsächlich so 2003, 2004 vielleicht rum...
...oder 2003 rum so das System...
Ey, das ist... das ist... oder sagen wir eher 2002, 2003, hä?
Das ist richtig... fett für...
...damalige Zeit!
...169 Gigabyte Platte...
...und so kommt es hier zustande!
Ja, aber das als RAID 5, ne?
Das ist schon echt eine Ione!
Schaut mal nach, ob das hier...
...ein SCSI-RAID damals...
...das... gut, in meinem Server, ja...
...naja, gut, mehr müssen wir uns davon nicht angucken...
...Modest-Tops...
Heute hat Warzone 136 Gig, ja!
Das stimmt!
Ups!
Guck mal hier!
Ähm, heute... heute... oder wie viel Gig hat Warzone mittlerweile?
Das hat... reicht doch 136 nicht mehr, oder?
Das hat wahrscheinlich 336!
Hm...
Wie kann ich mein Smart Home Sachen in einem extra WLAN-Netzwerk stecken?
Hab nur ne Fritzbox, gar nicht!
Fritzboxen können nur... ähm...
...ein WLAN und ein Gäste-WLAN...
...wobei das Gäste-WLAN dir für dein Smart Home Zeug wahrscheinlich nichts bringt...
...wobei...
...ich lehne mich da... ich... vielleicht auch zu weit aus dem Fenster...
...vielleicht KÖNNEN Fritzboxen mittlerweile...
...auch mehrere WLANs...
...oder mehrere SSIDs, muss man ja eigentlich sagen...
...aber selbst das alleine...
...bringt es dir ja nicht...
...du willst ja auch netzwerktechnisch das Ganze beschränken, dass...
...deine Smart Home Geräte aus dem Smart Home WLAN nicht rauskommen...
...oder nur zu ganz bestimmten Sachen hin...
...da weiß ich nicht, inwieweit das mit der Fritzbox alles easy möglich ist...
...also ich hab's... ich hab's so gemacht...
...mein...
...ich hab' ne normales WLAN...
...ich hab' nen IoT-WLAN...
...und...
...die haben auch noch ein unterschiedliches VLAN drunter...
...damit ich zum Beispiel...
...meine...
...den Raspberry Pi da rein stellen kann...
...kabelgebunden...
...also ich hab... ich hab zum Beispiel...
...für die... für die Kameras hatte ich früher...
...nen Raspberry Pi...
...und da war quasi im gleichen VLAN drinne...
...wie die ganzen WLAN... wie das Default...
...meine Default WLAN SSID...
...das ist halt der Vorteil...
...da kannst du es besser trennen, wenn du noch ein eigenes VLAN drunter hast...
...da kannst du dann auch kabelgebundene Geräte reinpacken und sowas...
...und...
...da brauchst du ein paar gescheite Firewall-Regeln...
...dass die Sachen nur hin dürfen, wo sie hin sollen...
...am besten ist, wenn IoT-Sachen...
...nirgends wo hin dürfen...
...gerade wenn dann noch die original...
...China-Chinesen-Firma drauf ist...
...inwieweit sich das alles mit der Fritzbox realisieren lässt...
...keine Ahnung...
...ich schwa, es ist nett...
...können wir uns als nächstes angucken, was haben wir denn hier...
...was erfolgreiche Programmierer tun...
...und du wahrscheinlich nicht...
...das klingt ein bisschen nach einem GBAIT-Titel...
...guck mal hier...
...schau wieder, was sollen wir hier gucken...
...das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf, das haben wir doch schon geguckt...
...ok, was hat das für Probleme...
...welchen Router du dann brauchst...
...ein Router alleine...
...wird es dir wahrscheinlich nicht reichen...
...du brauchst...
...auch...
...Axis Points...
...kann man so pauschal nicht sagen...
...also ich habe eine Kombination aus...
...man sieht...
...das sieht man in meinem letzten Video witzigerweise ganz gut...
...das ist da zwar überhaupt nicht dafür gedacht...
...hallo Leute, hier ist der Max...
...hier sieht man das ganz gut, also hier sieht man...
...also einmal mein Switch...
...gucken wir mal, ob man den vielleicht ein bisschen besser sieht...
...also man sieht einmal mein Switch...
...das ist ein Ubiquiti...
...Edge Switch 16 ES16XG...
...oder so...
...heißt das Ding...
...hm...
...das ist für...
...10 Gig...
...reiner 10 Gig Switch...
...der aber natürlich auch...
...1 Gig, 2,5...
...und 5 Gig kann...
...aktuell sieht das bei mir so aus...
...das hier ist...
...10G...
...zum File Server...
...und das hier 10G...
...als Uplink zu einem...
...kleineren Switch, den ich hier neben stehen hab...
...noch...
...das hier sind tatsächlich nochmal...
...drei...
...ältere...
...SFP 1 Gig...
...Ports...
...die ich hier in die SFP Plus Slots...
...reingesteckt hab...
...und das sind 4x10 Gig...
...RJ45 Kupfer...
...wovon...
...glaube ich alle bis auf...
...einen auch nur mit einem...
...Gig gesynct sind...
...so zumindest das ist mein interner Switch...
...der ist jetzt gar nicht so relevant dafür...
...ich hab als Router...
...schrägstrich...
...Paketfilter, Firewall, so ein HEX PoE...
...am Start...
...die Anschlüsse sind folgendermaßen...
...hier ist...
...ich hoffe ich krieg das jetzt richtig hin...
...hier ist das...
...rosa Kabel...
...das ist jetzt wegen der Beleuchtung nicht so richtig rosa...
...sondern so ein bisschen ganz leicht rosa...
...das rosa Kabel geht an die Unity Media Box...
...für Internet...
...das...
...grüne Kabel...
...geht glaube ich...
...intern an Switch...
...hier oben irgendwo hin...
...und die anderen 3...
...die anderen 2...
...ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher wo jetzt was hingeht...
...gehen auf jeden Fall zu...
...WLAN Access Points...
...der eine WLAN Access Point...
...ist im Keller...
...der andere WLAN Access Point...
...hängt drüben im Wohnzimmer...
...an der Decke...
...und habe ich gesagt grün...
...blau...
...blaue Kabel meine ich...
...also das Ding verwende ich...
...da habe ich ein paar Firewall Regeln drinnen...
...und da sind auch die WLANs angelegt...
...wobei man halt sagen muss...
...das Mikrotik Zeug ist nicht unbedingt super einsteigerfreundlich...
...von der Konfiguration her...
...da gibt es bestimmt bessere Sachen...
...um ein eigenes IoT WLAN aufzumachen...
...ich habe keinen Bock...
...zu malen...
...weil ihr es seid...
...Draw IO...
...die nicht mal ein Draw IO heißt...
...was kennt ihr für gute Alternativen...
...zu Draw IO...
...ExkaliDraw gab es da noch...
...das ist auch nicht schlecht...
...da gibt es bestimmt 1000 Sachen...
...mitlerweile...
...hab ich noch irgendwas...
...Olles von mir...
...bau mal den Packet Tracer nach...
...mach ich jetzt nicht...
...hab ich das überhaupt noch drauf...
...ne Packet...
...Packet Tracer...
...tatsächlich...
...gibt es sogar zum installieren...
...keckel...
...nice...
...und man braucht ja da mittlerweile einen Account für...
...aber das ist ein kostenloser Account...
...also bei mir sieht das mittlerweile so aus...
...ich lösche...
...die Wolke behalte ich mal...
...und den Router hier unten behalte ich auch...
...ich lösche das mal...
...ich habe...
...mach mal alles weg...
...mach mal auch weg...
...also ich habe hier...
...eine...
...Fritz Box...
...Ex PoE...
...Switch...
...ist aber eigentlich kein Switch...
...ist es nicht so...
...dass laut Cisco...
...das Router Bild ist ein Switch...
...so Pfeile nach links und rechts hat nur...
...gibt es nicht...
...sind wir mal Netzwerktechnisch...
...nicht so korrekt...
...Access Point...
...wir suchen einfach nach WLAN...
...WiFi...
...AP1...
...AP2...
...so bei mir sieht das folgendermaßen aus...
...das schieben wir jetzt mal weg...
...also Switch...
...interner Switch ist easy...
...interner Switch da ist zum Beispiel mein...
...Desktop PC dran und...
...alles mögliche interne Zeug...
...ich mach mal stellvertretend hier ein paar Kisten...
...egal Spielekonsole...
...also interner...
...interner Switch da ist...
...da verwende ich weder WLANs...
...noch sonst was...
...interner 10 GB Switch...
...da ist das ganze Zeug dran...
...was ich hier intern hab...
...der kann zwar VLANs und alles...
...aber keine VLANs oder sonst was...
...einfach rein für internen...
...internen Traffic...
...der auch schnell sein muss...
...so dann ist in der Mitte...
...von dem ganzen so ziemlich der Hex PoE...
...der ist einmal verbunden intern...
...da können wir auch gleich...
...nochmal ne Firewall suchen...
...gibt es bestimmt noch ein schönes Firewall Bildchen...
...machen wir hier noch ne Firewall mit dabei...
...Router...
...Router Schrägstrich Firewall...
...und alles mögliche machende...
...so der geht dann einmal...
...zum...
...Vone Box...
...so der geht einmal ins Internet...
...der geht einmal ins Internet...
...und...
...hier im gleichen Netz...
...im gleichen Netz...
...ist nochmal ne Fritz Box...
...die Fritz Box...
...verwende ich tatsächlich nur für eine Sache...
...und das ist...
...Voibe und...
...Deckt Telefone...
...sonst macht die bei mir nichts...
...ach ja das stimmt nicht ganz...
...über die streue ich auch die Fritz...
...Thermostate an...
...die macht aber...
...sonst nichts großartiges...
...die ist auch in diesem äußeren Netz...
...die nirgends wo hin kommt...
...die Fritz Box kommt nirgends wo hin...
...die ist nur für...
...Voibe, Deckt und diese Thermostate zuständig...
...was ich machen könnte ist...
...ich könnte das hier zusammenfassen...
...ich könnte mir ne ordentliche Fritz Box kaufen...
...und die Vodafone Box und die Fritz Box zusammenfassen...
...ja das könnte ich machen...
...so und dann gehts weiter...
...dann hab ich die Access Points...
...hier noch dran...
...zwei Stück...
...Keller...
...das sind aktuell Rokus...
...R710...
...die ich da hab die hab ich gebraucht auf Ebay gekauft...
...und seit ich die hab...
...hab ich überhaupt keine Probleme mehr mit...
...WLAN jeglicher Art...
...die Dinger sind...
...schweineteuer aber gebraucht auf Ebay gehen sie...
...man kriegt aber bloß die älteren Modelle...
...auf Ebay gebraucht und dann kosten sie immer noch...
...so viel wie neu irgendeinen...
...Ubiquity Access Point...
...aber ich find die taugen einfach...
...und zwei Access Points...
...die hängen hier noch dran...
...Access Points Keller...
...Access Points Wohnzimmer...
...so und diese Access Points...
...läuft der Gäste weder ein Ticket Champ...
...noch...
...der ist dafür auch gar nicht gedacht gewesen...
...meinst du das was wir mal im Browser...
...gebaut haben dieses Plugin...
...für diese Access Points...
...das Browser Plugin das hab ich immer noch...
...zum Passwörter generieren sowas...
...aber das ist ja eher für IoT Geräte gewesen...
...so...
...dann haben wir einmal hier nen WLAN...
...wir machen das einfach mal so...
...das ist ja...
...ganz normales...
...Geräte WLAN...
...wählen wir das jetzt mal...
...und geben wir dem mal...
...ich weiß nämlich meine VLAN ID nicht...
...VLAN ID...
...5...
...ich weiß es echt nicht gerade aus dem Kopf...
...so und dann...
...haben wir noch ein zweites...
...haben wir noch...
...zweites WLAN...
...das legen wir jetzt einfach mal hier oben drüber...
...das ist...
...IoT WLAN...
...mit WLAN ID...
...1337...
...wenn man sich merken kann...
...so und...
...ich hab jetzt noch nen Raspberry Pi hier stehen...
...ja...
...ist ja kein Raspberry Pi...
...ist da eigentlich ein gescheites Bild für...
...kein Bock...
...aber irgendwie das da...
...Board...
...irgendwie sowas hier...
...so dann hab ich noch nen Raspberry Pi stehen...
...das ist aber ein Blödsinn...
...Single Board Computer...
...ok das jetzt...
...das ist jetzt...
...das ist echt schlimm...gibt es kein Bild für man...
...ja genau das ist jetzt unser Raspberry Pi...
...ok...
...da...
...da hab ich ein paar von aber nur...
...oh ja nice...erkennt man...erkennt man...
...erkennt man richtig gut alles...
...oh...
...das ist hier der Raspberry...Alter...
...was ist das...kann ich vielleicht mal please...
...ordentlich was dranschreiben...
...da jetzt...
...so das ist der Raspberry Pi...genau so...
...sieht der aus...so und nicht anders...alles klar...
...so und der Raspberry Pi...
...der ist jetzt...
...hier dran angeschlossen...
...also...
...nicht wirklich...aber...
...was sind das hier...
...der Raspberry Pi ist...
...lasst mal dran...ach das ist das letzte Kabel...
...gewesen...ich weiß...
...dass das dritte Kabel hingeht...
...das geht tatsächlich an Raspberry Pi...
...hmm...
...so...
...das geht an Raspberry Pi...
...und der ist auch...
...Wilan ID 5...
...da läuft zum Beispiel das Dashboard...
...für meine Überwachungskameras und sowas drauf...
...weil...
...das am einfachsten ist...
...dort so von den Wlan Geräten drauf zuzugreifen...
...ja ungefähr so...
...natürlich...
...kommen noch mehr Geräte dabei...aber...
...also zum Beispiel ist das auch nicht der einzige...
...Raspberry Pi...
...so ungefähr sieht das...
...bei mir aktuell aus...
...und wenn jetzt...sagen wir mal...
...die...
...IOT Geräte...
...irgendwohin müssen...dann dürfen die nicht...
...die dürfen nicht ins Internet...
...also wenn so ein IOT Gerät...
...sagen wir zum Beispiel hier irgendwie...
...hier...
...Walp...wenn ich das richtig schreiben kann...
...wie schreibt man...
...Walp für Glühbirne...Bulb...
...ja...
...wenn man da zum Beispiel mit Herzchen drin...
...so eine Glühbirne hat...
...so eine...
...China...
...Chinesen...
...Lampe...
...wie macht man in DrawIO die Farbe...
...Text...
...Fontcolor...Backgroundcolor muss weg...
...so...China-Chinesen-Lampe...
...hier im IOT Wlan...
...die da drin ist...
...sagen wir mal...
...die muss jetzt irgendwo hin...
...drauf zugreifen um die Uhrzeit...
...zusetzen...was bescheuert...das ist jetzt nur mal ein Beispiel...
...ja...dann habe ich hier...
...eine Firewall-Freischaltung drin...
...die NTP erlaubt...
...zum Beispiel...oder nehmen wir mal...
...was realistischeres...
...wir haben hier eine...
...eine Steckdosenleiste...
...die...
...exakt...
...so aussieht...
...China...
...Chinesen-Steckdosenleiste...
...also ein ganz gutes Beispiel...
...ja...
...haben wir auch hier im IOT Wlan...
...drinnen...
...und da ist es jetzt so...
...die muss ja...
...hier unten...
...ist meine...
...mein Home Assistant...
...das ist im Internet...
...und da läuft ja unter anderem...
...nennen wir das einfach MQTT...so...
...jetzt kommt natürlich diese...
...Steckdosenleiste...
...nicht an den MQTT-Server...
...hier unten dran...
...und da gibt es explizit...
...nur für diese eine Sache...
...auf diese eine Ziel-IP...
...und für dieses eine Gerät...
...dann eine Firewall-Freischaltung...
...wobei ich weiß nicht ob es für das eine...
...doch wahrscheinlich habe ich es nur für das eine Gerät gemacht...
...kommt dann direkt...
...eine Firewall-Freischaltung dahin...
...allerdings...
...bei mir stellt sich das Problem gar nicht...
...ich habe die China-Chinesen Steckdosenleiste geflasht...
...und da mache ich mir wenig...
...Gedanken...
...und dadurch das die geflasht ist...
...könnte man die wenn man die will sogar daran hängen...
...aber ich glaube...
...die meisten selbst geflashten...
...IoT Sachen habe ich hier...
...dran hängen...
...und das schöne hier an dem ist...
...hier habe ich...
...DPSK...
...mit DPSK...
...das heißt jedes meiner...
...IoT WLAN Geräte hat ein...
...eines Passwort für das WLAN...
...und mal angenommen die Lampe geht jetzt...
...kaputt und ich schmeiße die Lampe...
...weg...
...dann lösche ich einfach...
...den...
...User...
...ne User ist das falsche Wort...
...dann lösche ich einfach das WLAN Passwort für die Lampe...
...und egal...
...wer das WLAN Passwort jemals aus dieser...
...Lampe wieder...
...extrahieren sollte kann damit nicht...
...nicht mehr anfangen und sich nicht mal mehr ins...
...IoT WLAN einloggen...
...ist also jedes einzelne WLAN Gerät...
...wenn die zumindest die neue aufgesetzt...
...haben eigene Passwörter...
...also ein DMZ...
...WLAN...
...DMZ ist ja in der Regel immer...
...Zugang von außen...
...also der richtige DMZ ist etwas...
...was sich zwischen...
...zwei Firewalls befindet nämlich...
...einmal zwischen außen und der innen Firewall...
...und quasi Traffic...
...von außen...
...nach innen auf die DMZ erlaubt...
...und von innen in die DMZ...
...also...
...nicht wirklich WLAN DMZ...
...weil die hat jedes IOT Gerät dasselbe...
...Passwort ja das ist ein Problem deswegen...
...eines der Sachen warum ich kein Ubiquiti...
...Ubiquiti mehr verwende...
...weil die sich seit Jahren...
...davor drücken...
...das zu implementieren...
...das ist nicht mit Radius ne...
...und weil die sich seit Jahren...
...davor drücken...
...ach ja...
...die können das jetzt auch...
...nach 5 Jahren haben sie es geschafft...
...ich weiß...
...Moment was ist...
...Unify Network...
...ist das die Firmware...
...ist das die Firmware Version...
...dann muss ich mal angucken...
...wie die das da...
...na finally alter...
...alder die haben so lange...
...ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen...
...die haben so lange dafür gebraucht...
...dass ich mir mittlerweile neue Access Points...
...von einem anderen Hersteller gekauft habe...
...äh...
...Moment Moment Moment...
...ne ne ne ne ne...
...das ist was anderes...
...allow you to use different passwords...
...on the same WiFi...
...from different virtual networks...
...nein nein nein nein...
...das ist nicht pro Client...
...die können das...
...pro WLAN...
...das ist auch schon wieder Schrott man...
...das bringt überhaupt nichts...
...weil es das Problem nicht löst...
...das Problem doch überhaupt nicht...
...die eigentliche Problemstellung...
...ist...
...du hast ein Gerät in deinem WLAN hängen...
...in deinem IOT WLAN...
...ist auch egal...
...du hast die China Steckdosenleiste...
...in deinem IOT WLAN...
...die geht kaputt...
...du schmeißt sie weg...
...irgendjemand extrahiert dein WLAN Passwort da draus...
...und kann sich in dein IOT WLAN einwählen...
...und von dort dann...
...es ist ja egal wie restriktiv das ist...
...und es ist auch erstmal egal...
...wie wahrscheinlich das ist...
...aber das ist ja...
...die grundlegende Problemstellung...
...die es zu lösen gilt...
...und damit lösen...
...dieses Problem löst du nicht mit...
...unterschiedliche Passwörter pro WLAN...
...sondern das löst du mit unterschiedlichen Passwörtern pro Gerät...
...dann musst du dich wieder damit beschäftigen...
...wie du unwiederbringlich...
...deine Geräte zerstörst...
...und mal ganz im Ernst...
...versuch mal...
...ja aber WPA Enterprise können die meisten Geräte nicht...
...bringt es das...bringt es das nicht...
...WPA Enterprise können die meisten Geräte nicht...
...Mac Adresse ACL...
...bringt es auch nicht...
...kann sich einfach auslesen...
...von dem Gerät...
...also man kann beliebig drum herum doktoren...
...um das Problem oder man löst es richtig...
...nämlich mit DPSK...
...das geht seit dem letzten Update...
...das geht pro Client...
...aber das sagt die...
...das Changelog sagt es aber nicht...
...das Changelog...
...oder geht das in der noch neueren Version...
...also hier sieht man...
...eindeutig nur unterschiedliche...
...Passwörter pro WLAN ID...
...gucken wir mal...
...gucken wir doch mal...
...was die hier dazu sagen...
...was bin ich hier überhaupt sehend gerade...
...was ist Uni Hosted...
...was soll das sein...
...we host Unify Controllers in the Cloud...
...ok das ist im Prinzip das gleiche...
...was man auch selbst hosten kann...
...ich würde denen mal einen Tipp geben...
...für Screenshots...
...eventuell in der Größe wo man was erkennen kann...
...auf der Webseite...
...nicht erst die man extra öffnen muss...
...Add Passwords to the Configuration...
...Nee...
...das geht nur pro WLAN ID...
...und das ist halt scheiße...
...das kann man halt nicht gebrauchen...
...das löst das Problem nicht...
...da steht...
...WLAN ID 02 Passwörter...
...eh...
...da steht Network WLAN ID...
...so das heißt du kannst...
...pro WLAN ID ein Passwort vergeben...
...was ja sinnlos ist...
...du willst ja pro Gerät ein Passwort vergeben...
...du hast ja auch gar kein Add Button für neues Gerät...
...oder sowas hier unten...
...also wenn das geht...
...ist die Oberfläche nicht eindrucksvoll...
...hier sieht mans ja...
...guck...
...Manual...
...manual...
...und jetzt...
...du kannst nur die VLANs auswählen...
...das ist für'n Arsch man...
...was haben sie denn da wieder...
...häh...
...Moment...
...jetzt blick ich's nicht...
...also doch...
...du kannst doch mehrere...
...du kannst es doch pro Gerät machen...
...aber...
...warum kannst du nicht dahinter schreiben...
...für welches Gerät das ist...
...wie willst du denn das jetzt wiederfinden...
...jetzt stell dir mal vor...
...für Glühbirne ABC...
...wie finde ich dann wieder Glühbirne ABC...
...da kannst du ja überhaupt keinen Text...
...oder sowas hinten dran schreiben...
...aber das UI...
...dann geht das doch...
...dann ist die Beschreibung einfach nur absolut pepega...
...und wie kannst du es locken lassen...
...also...
...ich kann euch jetzt mal erklären...
...wie das bei mir funktioniert...
...Moment...
...wir haben das doch gebaut...
...im Stream...
...äh...
...Browser...
...wie hieß das denn...
...webinterface modden...
...genau...
...bei mir sieht das folgendermaßen aus...
...mein Access Point hat auch nicht...
...1500€ gekostet...
...sondern auf Ebay...
...also bei mir sieht das folgendermaßen aus...
...die Anleitung die man hier findet...
...ist natürlich schon wieder komplett bescheuert...
...ist jetzt wieder...
...findest wieder nichts dazu...
...im Prinzip ist das...
...total simpel...
...ja...
...man findet keine gescheiten Spiele...
...also im Prinzip ist das simpel...
...du klickst den Webinterface hinzufügen...
...für neues Gerät...
...dort...
...lässt du dann ein Passwort generieren...
...du kannst dir noch ein QR Code...
...generieren lassen...
...den du bei den Geräten einscannen lassen kannst...
...das ist auch nice...
...und dann...
...verfolgt es sich beim ersten Connect...
...die MAC Adresse...
...von dem Gerät...
...das heißt es geht nur die Kombination...
...diese MAC Adresse...
...mit diesem Passwort...
...und selbst wenn...
...jetzt wenn du das Gerät wegwirfst...
...und es jemand klaut...
...dieses Passwort ist ja gelöscht...
...also sprich du hast komplett das Problem behoben...
...sollte jemand das Gerät aus dem Müll...
...holen und den Controller auslesen...
...außerdem...
...möchte ich nochmal darauf hinweisen...
...es ist gar nicht so einfach Geräte ordentlich zu zerstören...
...überlegt guckt euch mal sowas an...
...ihr habt ein...
...davon hatte ich ein paar Microcontroller...
...so ein ganz kleiner...
...ESP32 Microcontroller...
...wenn nicht eines der kleinsten...
...so Leute versucht mal so ein Ding...
...ordentlich zu zerstören...
...wenn ihr nicht das passende Equipment dafür habt...
...Bohrmaschine...
...damit geht es ja schon mal los...
...an welcher Stelle bohrst du denn überhaupt...
...wenn du dich...
...damit nicht weiter beschäftigt hast...
...an welcher Stelle bohrst du...
...Hammer...
...ich würde mich nicht darauf verlassen...
...wenn ich da mit dem Hammer...
...also erstens...
...ist das Ding ziemlich robust...
...und wenn du mit dem Hammer drauf haust...
...würde ich auch nicht unbedingt sagen...
...dass du gerade den Speicher erwischst...
...der dann kaputt ist...
...also am besten wäre...
...hexeln...
...ein Häcksler...
...der sowas häckseln kann daheim...
...da kannst du ja nicht einfach in deinen Mixer...
...Mixer schmeißen...
...da sind relativ stabile Metallteile dabei...
...einfach am besten...
...wenn häckseln oder einschmelzen...
...das sind alles so nicht so richtig praktikable Sachen...
...also deutlich...deutlich einfacher...
...deutlich einfacher...
...einschmelzen...
...deutlich einfacher ist es doch...
...das einfach wegschmeißen zu können...
...und sich überhaupt keine Gedanken...
...darüber machen zu müssen...
...wenn das Passwort eh nicht mehr gültig ist...
...oder wir schicken es an den Hydraulic...
...Pressed Channel...
...der Hydraulic presst dann...
...meinen ESP32...
...in die Sonne schießen...
...oder in einen Vulkan werfen...
...sehr gute praktikable Idee Chat...
...easy...
...Problem gelöst...
...easy as fuck...
...auch sehr günstig...
...also ihr seht die Probleme sind teilweise...
...gar nicht so einfach zu lösen...
...wie man denkt...
...und so eine technische Lösung...
...dass das einfach nicht mehr möglich ist...
...mit dem Passwort irgendwas anzufangen...
...ja besser oder...
...was ist das denn...
...Mini-Schredder...
...Ding des Monats...
...ok dann lass mal schreddern...
...ja wie man sieht ist das jetzt gar nicht in Aktion...
...oh das ist ja kacke...
...das red nicht richtig...
...da muss jetzt ja noch ein ordentlicher Motor dran...
...ein Stück Papier...
...ein Stück Papier kann ich mir auch...
...mit was anderem schreddern...
...ein Stück Pappe kann ich auch mit was anderem schreddern...
...eine Karte krieg ich auch noch...
...mit was anderem geschreddert...
...so Metallteile...
...so USB-Anschlüsse und so...
...bin mir nicht sicher ob das das Ding schafft...
...also ich glaube das Ding hätte Probleme...
...mit so einem ESP32 Board...
...ok 3D gedrucktes Zeug...
...ok ok...
...aber immer noch nicht...
...in der Intensität wie ich mir so ein ESP32 Board...
...vorstelle...
...das ist auch sehr dünn...
...ich mein die Dinger sind ne also...
...die sind stabil...
...die Teile...
...die sind klein und die sind stabil...
...allein schon die Metallanschlüsse hier drauf...
...und das ist auch nicht so dünn...
...so PCBs und gerade so...
...die Metallsachen die sind schon echt stabil...
...also ich trau das dem Ding nicht zu...
...das ordentlich zu schreddern...
...Chat was meinst du...
...würde das Ding das hier schreddern...
...ich hätte meine Bedenken...
...gerade beim USB Anschluss...
...glaub ich nicht das es das ordentlich schreddert...
...natürlich...
...ja du hast das...
...du kennst dich mit Microcontroller...
...stell es aus...
...wie schredderst du deine Controller...
...ich weiß es nicht...
...es macht schon ein...
...this shredder is a beast...
...jetzt gucken wir uns ernsthaft...
...Schredder Videos an...
...ok das ist ein Schredder zum Handdrehen...
...ist auch nicht verkehrt...
...erst mal schön den Finger reinstecken...
...warum genau wird das hier geschreddert...
...oh Mensch...
...was es nicht alles gibt...
...dem Ding würde ich zutrauen...
...wobei das auch ganz schön...
...ok wenn es das schafft...
...würde ich davon ausgehen...
...das schafft das Board auch...
...das ist halt ein PCB mit USB Anschlüssen...
...und sowas...
...aber dem würde ich das zutrauen...
...hahaha...
...ok...
...wenn das schafft...
...dann schafft es mein PCB auf jeden Fall...
...
programmierer machen erfolgreiche programmierer das jetzt mal in kontext zu bringen erfolgreiche
programmierer updaten ihre software vielleicht öfters als alle zwei jahre die programmieren
halt einfach auch mal und lasst uns nicht rumgammeln wir gucken uns mal was erfolgreiche
programmierer machen okay ein erfolgreicher programmierer von einem durchschnittlichen du
denkst vielleicht sind die klassischen antworten die wir auch von google erhalten zum beispiel
produktiv sein lösungsorientiert arbeiten oder auch einfach nur fristen im griff haben das ding
ist aber wenn man halt fehlerfrei ich wollte es gerade sagen wenn man fehlerfreie software
entwickelt was der fiat champ ja offensichtlich ist wie man hier sieht dann braucht man auch keine
updates weil wenn es funktioniert dann funktioniert das hier sind offensichtlich alles anwendungsfehler
kann ich ja nichts für wenn die leute es einfach nicht benutzen können nur die spitze des eisbeeren
in meiner laufbahn habe ich drei entscheidende gewohnheiten entdeckt die die erfolgreichsten
softwareentwickler ausmacht und diese geheimnisse die will ich heute mit ihr teilen okay diese hätte
auch nicht viele stunden des lernens erspart sondern auch einfach mit glücklicher beim
programmieren gemacht also gute software erkennt man am preis genau es muss einfach nur teuer sein
deswegen ist sap und oracle auch das geilste was es gibt lasst uns gleich anfangen vor allem er
verbreitete ratschlag den ich damals als anfänger häufiger hören musste war dieser hier um ein guter
programmierer zu werden musst du täglich programmieren und das hört sich im ersten
moment auch logisch an denn übung macht den meisten nicht zwangsläufig aber es hat echt
also ganz ehrlich wenn man okay vielleicht nicht unbedingt war ein guter programmierer werden will
aber wenn man ein erfolgreicher programmierer werden will dann bedeutet das ja auch man hat
projekte die in gewisser weise erfolgreich sind und da muss man schon am ballplatz
bleiben sonst ändert das endet das wieder fiat champ athena dankeschön für den sap und außerdem
gucken die gescheite programmierer regelmäßig bubblos logisch aber so einfach ist das nun auch wieder
nicht was uns dafür kurz die welt des programmierens verlassen hat im c was ach nein fatty mac fettzack
jetzt habe ich verstanden backflyer dankeschön für die ganzen subs dafür betrachten wir tim mit doppel m
hat sich vorgenommen klavierspielen zu lernen und will daraus eine kleine karriere machen ähnlich wie
beim programmieren erfordert das klavierspielen auch motorische und mentale exzellent man könnte meinen
die tastatur ist die karte any any piano players hier wo habe ich denn mein pfeiffer im mode ich
sehe es gar nicht wird des programmierers elb also stundenlang jeden tag denn klar wie entscheidend
den meister oder er spielt immer die gleichen stücke die gleichen tonarten die gleichen
tonleiter immer und immer wieder anfangs macht er dadurch auch richtig schnell richtig doch das
sollte nicht für immer so bleiben er übt zwar aber übt da hier jetzt eigentlich wirklich nach
einer weile stellt dann auch fest dass er so ein bisschen die motivation für die musik verliert und
er spielt eigentlich nur noch aus pflichtgefühl was werden wir jetzt daraus es ist nicht die
menge des lebens die zählen sondern die qualität des übens ich würde sagen beides ich also keine
ich würde sagen beides man kann es jetzt nicht sicherlich nicht so eins zu eins übertragen aus
programmieren aber sagen wir mal auf was anderes es gibt doch ja ist das trainings
pyramide oder sowas trainings pyramide das meine ich nicht
training pyramide
ja so sehr sinngemäß ja also das wichtigste ist regelmäßig ich finde ich finde hier beständigkeit
ja hier trifft man das sowas in der richtung das wichtigste ist regelmäßig das ist das so was in
der richtung habe ich habe ich gemeint dass es tritt das ist nicht genau das was ich meine das
ist nicht das ist nicht genau das was ich meine aber dass das wichtigste ist regelmäßig die sachen
machen
ins Volume-Up-Training. Das Wichtigste ist regelmäßig.
Danach kann man sich,
also, du kannst
super krass die Gedanken machen,
ja, und dir das super krasse Equipment
kaufen und das ganz tolle
irgendwie Protein-Dinger und sonst
was. Derjenige, der
fünfmal die Woche rennt, wird trotzdem
nach einem Jahr deutlich fitter
sein als jeder, der nur zweimal die
Woche rennt und super High-IQ-Training
macht. Selbst wenn der Typ
einfach nur stumpf
fünfmal die Woche
seine, seine,
ja, paar Kilometer rennt,
wenn der andere nur zweimal rennt
und super High-IQ-Schuhe
hat und was auch immer, dann ist trotzdem der
nach einem Jahr fitter, der fünfmal
rennt. Also,
Frequenz ist echt das Wichtigste.
Ab einer gewissen Menge
wären natürlich andere Sachen wichtig, ja.
Ob es jetzt ein Riesenunterschied ist,
ob einer
fünfmal oder sechsmal
trainiert,
versus
dann die Feinheiten,
da kann man sich drüber streiten, aber bei
großen Quantitätsunterschieden wird
der, der einfach mehr macht, auf lange
Sicht auch der sein, der besser ist.
Nochmal ein anderes
Beispiel. Guckt
euch mal klassische
Musikkomponisten
an, wo wir gerade bei
Piano und Klavier waren und so.
Die meisten davon
haben enorm viel
Zeug rausgehauen.
Die waren super,
super produktiv, die
mussten, nicht alle, nicht alle,
ja, aber die meisten, die meisten
waren super produktiv.
Ich mein, die haben damit ja auch Geld verdient, ja.
Und ganz
vieles davon ist
so richtig 0 auf 15.
Aber ein paar Stücke, so bei jedem
Komponist, die ragen halt raus.
Da hat er sich halt wirklich selbst übertroffen.
Aber trotzdem, die
meisten haben massig Zeug rausgehauen
und haben dann aber auch den ein oder anderen
...
richtig, richtig, richtig
bekannten Hit gelandet, quasi.
Ich sag das mit klassischer Musik,
weil das ist oft genug analysiert
worden. Ist heute bestimmt
ähnlich noch. Die Menge
macht schon viel aus. Warum
sind dann alle bei LOL so scheiße?
Moment, du nicht. Ich denke nur deine
Teammates, oder?
Am Anfang deiner Programmierkarriere
ist es wirklich hilfreich, viel
zu üben, denn hier erreichst du Qualität
durch Quantität. Aber nach einer
gewissen Zeit musst du da strategisch sein.
Die fünfte To-Do-App,
die ist vielleicht gut, um dir jetzt nochmal die ...
Da hat er natürlich recht.
Wenn man nicht über Hallo Welt
rauskommt, ist auch egal, ob ich 20 Mal
Hallo Welt mache. Das ist schon klar.
Konzepte zu festigen, oder auch einfach ...
Aber das kommt, also ganz ehrlich,
das kommt
allein dadurch, wenn es einen persönlich
interessiert.
Wenn man das Thema nur macht, weil es in der Schule
dran kommt, dann wird man
da, ja, da wird man
keinen Spaß dran haben.
Wenn man das persönlich interessiert, und wenn man auch
immer wieder so neue Gebiete hat, die
einen interessiert, in die man sich einarbeitet,
dann
wird man auch immer wieder sich
mit neuen Technologien auseinandersetzen
müssen, ja. Zum Beispiel, als
wir im Stream, haben wir doch mal so
ein FFM-Pack
in ...
im Browser gebaut.
FFM-Pack mit, wie hieß das nochmal,
also für
WebAssembly, wie hieß
das nochmal mit irgendeiner
C++-Library, irgendeinem C++
Cross-Compiler, so.
Und das war was, das habe ich im Vorfeld
noch nie gemacht. Da habe ich enorm viel bei gelernt,
das meiste habe ich mittlerweile wieder vergessen.
Aber warum? Weil es mich
zu dem Zeitpunkt brennend interessiert hat,
wie der Scheiß funktioniert.
Das meiste habe ich wieder vergessen. Ich meine, ich habe
den Source Code noch irgendwo, da könnte ich nachgucken.
Aber das ist immer so. Und ja, und dann
interessiere ich mich für Microcontroller, dann
interessiere ich mich für WebRTC, und dann
macht man auch einfach mal
1, 2, vielleicht
3 Monate ganz viel in diesem Thema.
Und weil es einen persönlich
interessiert, wird man dann auch ganz gut drin.
Also ich gebe ihm schon recht,
mit dem 500. Hello World kommst du nicht weiter.
Nächstes Thema.
Ja, dumme Schwätzer, immer.
Ja.
Also bei den Leuten, die immer am größten
tönen, dass sie die geilsten sind, also
machen wir mal ein Beispiel.
Ich hatte ja jetzt in der letzten
Firma die ein oder anderen Azubis,
um die ich mich kümmern musste.
Und wir hatten welche, die
haben mir schon quasi in den ersten paar Tagen
erzählt, sie machen die Ausbildung ja
eigentlich nur, damit sie dann
einen Abschluss haben, und sie können
das alles, und der
IHK-Abschluss, der kommt halt nicht von
alleine, deswegen müssen sie jetzt die Ausbildung
machen, und die wissen das schon.
Und
das waren oftmals die Leute, mit denen ich am größten
Probleme hatte. Weil
das war so eine Kombination aus
von sich voll überzeugt, aber
meistens kein Plan.
Das ist eine scheiß Kombination.
Da war auch dazu
gehörte auch der Typ, erinnert
ihr euch noch an das Video, was ich gemacht habe,
wo es um den Typ ging, der versucht hat
bei uns im Rechenzentrum irgendeinen Filesharing-Dienst
zu hosten?
Ja, gehörte da auch dabei.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nicht, nicht, nicht, nicht mit
dem Shit-Repo. Mit dem Shit-Repo
war Herr Endpunkt.
Mit Herr Endpunkt hatte ich auch meine Probleme,
ja. Übrigens, wisst ihr, dass ich gestern mit
Herr Endpunkt Discord telefoniert
hab, ne Stunde,
und
wir haben uns überlegt, ob wir nicht
ob wir nicht mal so ein
ähm, der Werdegang
des Herr Endpunkts
machen wollen. Aber ich weiß, da brauchen wir
ein bisschen, bisschen schön
ja, ja, ja, den
meinte ich nicht, den meinte, Herr Endpunkt
hat nie versucht, bei uns im Rechenzentrum illegale
Filesharing-Sachen zu hosten.
Ja, ähm, zumindest hab ich gehört,
der ist jetzt bei einer Bank in Frankfurt
gelandet. Wer hätte das gedacht?
Irgendwie landen so früher oder
später alle bei irgendwelchen Banken
in Frankfurt.
Und ist dort jetzt verantwortlich
für die, ach,
er hat's mir gestern erzählt,
für irgendwen, für irgendein größeres
IT-System. Da hört man sich tatsächlich
auch mal drüber, weil der hat
echt einen ganz interessanten Gang.
Der ist jetzt hinter sich,
finde ich, weil
der hat ja keinen allzu guten Start.
Keinen allzu guten Start bei uns.
Und der wurde ja auch, das war eines
der wenigen Azubis, der nicht übernommen wurde.
Hat's auch richtig verkackt. Ich glaube, das hat er
auch mittlerweile eingesehen.
Danach hat er ja erst mal nichts gefunden.
Dann war er, danach war er bei so einer
Personalvermittlungsagentur oder so
Personalverschacherungsding.
Und zumindest hat er's
jetzt geschafft,
wo zu landen, was taugt.
Das letzte Mal, wo ich mit ihm telefoniert
hab, war er im IBM-Host-Umfeld tätig.
Aber macht er jetzt nicht mehr.
Hat ja auch nicht so wirklich große Zukunft.
Der ist ja noch jünger als ich.
Ist ja, keine Ahnung, wie alt er jetzt sein wird.
26, 27
oder so. Ja, 28 vielleicht.
Ich glaube, bei uns war er gerade um die 20.
Müsste jetzt 28 oder so sein.
Also ungefähr so alt, wie ich
mit YouTube angefangen habe. Nein, nicht ganz.
Da war ich schon ein bisschen jünger.
Wo ich arbeite, sag ich nicht.
Dort, wo ich
Hähnepunkte in der Ausbildung hatte,
arbeite ich auch nicht mehr.
Und dort, wo ich den Azubi hatte,
der Filesharing
im Rechenzentrum hosten wollte, da arbeite ich auch nicht mehr.
Meinung zu Uni-Absolventen
in der IT. Kommt auf den
Uni-Absolventen an, oder?
Was ist dieses Buchstaben
kopieren? Ja.
Richtig, richtig.
Von Max ist kompiliert so großes
IT-System. Ja, ist echt so bei ihm.
Hähnepunkt war
derjenige, dem ich
als Übungsaufgabe
gestellt hatte,
er soll einen BMI-Rechner programmieren.
So Konsoleneingabe.
Und ich meine, es ist
wirklich nicht schwierig, einen BMI-Rechner
zu programmieren. Es sollte
eine Konsolenanwendung sein,
so nach dem Motto,
geben Sie Ihre Größe ein, geben Sie Ihr
Alter und Gewicht ein, und dann soll er einen BMI ausrechnen.
Also super simpel. Das sind irgendwie, keine Ahnung, fünf
Zeilen oder so. Und da
hat er irgendwie zwei Trage dran rumgemacht und
irgendwann ist er halt zu mir gekommen und hat dann gesagt,
Max, ich hab's geschafft, es geht, es geht.
Und im Endeffekt hat es halt das erste
Mal kompiliert.
Und dann hat er, er hat's halt
nicht in Rust programmiert. Hätte er's in Rust
programmiert, hätte es jetzt auch funktioniert.
So, und dann ist es gestartet.
Und da kam dann halt so eine Konso, ist halt,
kam halt, ne,
kam halt eine Konsole, und da stand
dann sowas wie so, geben
Sie Ihr Alter
ein. So, und
dann, dann hat er halt erwartet,
dass ich dann da eingebe, keine Ahnung,
29, und ich hab halt eingegeben,
A, B, C, und Enter gedrückt. Und das Ding ist direkt gecrashed.
Dann war, nein, du kannst da doch
nicht Buchstaben eingeben.
Tja.
Dann hat er nochmal irgendwie zwei Tage,
ich glaube, er hat's irgendwann aufgegeben.
Ich glaube, er hat's irgendwann aufgegeben.
Okay, was war der erfolgreiche Programmierer
noch? BMI-Rechner programmiert.
...einfache Aufgabe gegeben hatte.
Doch die Zeit verging und verging,
es gab aber keinen so rechten Fortschritt.
Als ich dann nachgehakt habe,
habe ich herausgefunden, dass er sich einfach nicht
so sicher mit der von uns verwendeten
Programmiersprache gefühlt hat.
Ja, aber er hat sich nicht getraut, was zu sagen, weil er im Vorfeld
so groß rumgetönt hat, dass er alles schon kann.
Das ist halt auch doof.
Statt um Hilfe zu bitten, hat er versucht, alle Probleme
allein zu lösen. Da soll jetzt hier in keinster Weise
Werkstudenten wäschen, denn von Anfängern
und auch von Fortgeschrittenen wird nicht
erwartet, dass sie alles wissen und...
Ehrlich gesagt,
ganz im Ernst, ich habe
mittlerweile mir das abgeschminkt,
in Bereichen, wo ich, wenn
ich was nicht weiß, so zu tun als wüsste ich.
Zum Beispiel,
ich meine, ich kann Ansible,
ich kann Sachen in Ansible erstellen, ich kann Ansible lesen,
ich kann Ansible ausführen, ich kann Ansible ändern,
alles. Was ich nicht weiß ist,
wenn ich ein großes Ansible-Modul
vor mir habe, wie man es
benutzt und was es genau macht.
Und meinte auch
letztens irgendjemand, ja,
wie wäre es denn,
willst du nicht mal probieren, die und die Server aufzubauen?
Und ich sagte, ja, wenn es das Server aufbauen
wäre, wäre das kein Problem. Da brauchst
du irgendwie 15 Ansible-Module, von denen ich keine Ahnung
habe, wie man sie benutzt und was sie genau machen.
Also, du hast das schon gemacht,
ich kenne die nicht, also somit, ich baue meine
halbe Stunde auf, das geht halt nicht.
Keine Ahnung von.
Ist mir dann auch eingeleuchtet, aber
es hat ja keinen Sinn, dann zu sagen,
ja, easy mache ich, wenn es halt
nicht easy ist.
Wenn ich das zwei-, dreimal gemacht habe,
ist das überhaupt kein Ding. Zumal,
das heißt nicht, dass unsere Ansible-Module
sonderlich schön wären oder so,
dass man die gut lesen könnte.
Außerdem bin ich eh nicht
so der große Ansible-Enjoyer.
Ich finde Ansible ist ganz nice, wir haben es ja auch im Stream schon
ein paarmal verwendet. Aber wenn ich
drumherum komme, dann versuche ich
drumherum zu kommen. Also, wenn ich mit
Terraform für Infrastruktur und ein Cloud-Init
File auskomme für ein paar Sachen,
dann mache ich einen großen Bogen
um Ansible.
Du musst nicht alles können, das stimmt.
Aber von dir wird erwartet, dass du Fragen stellst,
dann, wenn du nicht weiterkommst oder dich sehr unsicher
fühlst. Das bringt mich auch zum Kern des Punktes.
Um ein erfolgreicher Programmierer zu sein,
darfst du nicht von deinem Ego gefangen sein.
Es ist vollkommen in Ordnung, um Hilfe
zu bitten, denn das zeigt nicht von
Schwäche, sondern davon, dass du lernen
wirst. Wichtig ist, man muss wissen, welche Leute
man um Hilfe fragen kann.
Weil,
kennt ihr die Situation, dass ihr
irgendwie nicht genau weiter wisst?
Aber ihr wisst
auch, wenn ihr jetzt
irgendwo hingeht und um Hilfe fragt,
dann ist das wahrscheinlich
deutlich
langwieriger, als wenn
ihr einfach jetzt eine Stunde googelt.
Also mal angenommen, es gibt irgendwie
Thema, irgendwie Zertifikate
irgendwie
Thema Zertifikate
SSL-Verschlüsselung. Irgendwie habt ihr Probleme, ja?
So, ihr könntet jetzt zu den Leuten
gehen, die
sich bei euch mit Zertifikaten und Verschlüsselung
und sowas beschäftigen.
Und in denen euer Problem erklären und ihr hofft,
dass die eine Antwort drauf haben. Oder ihr
googelt lieber eine Stunde und findet die Antwort selbst.
In der Regel habe ich die Erfahrung gemacht,
wenn mir nicht sofort jemand
einfällt, den ich dazu fragen
kann, beziehungsweise wo ich mir sofort
denke, okay, der hat richtig Planer
von, der weiß das, dann google ich lieber
eine Stunde, weil die meisten
Sachen, die
meisten Sachen
arten immer aus, wenn du Leute
fragst.
Du fragst Leute so nach dem Motto, ey,
mir fällt jetzt
echt kein gutes Beispiel ein. Ja,
mach mal ein anderes Beispiel.
Machen wir nicht Zertifikate, machen wir nicht Zertifikate.
Machen wir mal was ganz
Simples, ja, so hier.
Ihr wollt, ihr wollt farbige
Konsolenausgabe haben.
Hier, hier, farbige Konsolenausgabe
wollt ihr haben, so. Und ihr kommt damit
nicht klar. Ihr habt das noch nie gemacht und
ihr habt keine Ahnung, was jetzt da
für, warum es nicht funktioniert.
Ja, ihr habt keine, angenommen ihr habt hier,
keine Ahnung, ihr habt das, ihr habt das Komma an der
Stelle vergessen, so. Und ihr habt keine Ahnung, warum
das nicht funktioniert, so.
Ihr kennt jetzt jemand, der richtig krasser
Bash-Hackerman ist und,
also angenommen, ich würde das nicht hinkriegen und
ich kenne jetzt jemand, der übelst krass Bash-Hackerman ist,
von dem ich zig Skripte kenne, wo ich
weiß, der macht da Konsolenausgabe
und aus irgendwelchen Gründen checke ich es nicht, obwohl ich
mir seine Skripte angeguckt habe, dann würde
ich den fragen. Dann würde ich sagen, ey,
Kollege, wie sieht es aus?
Wie machst du immer deine nice Farbausgabe?
Und wenn ich weiß, dass es jemand ist, der
unkompliziert ist, dass er sagt,
ach ja, guck mal, du hast das Semikolon
vergessen, easy. Dann frage ich den, da ist
es in fünf Minuten erledigt und sonst was.
So.
Das Ding ist jetzt
nur, dass es bei den meisten Leuten ausartet.
Die meisten Leute, die würdest du fragen
und die sind
sich dann selber nicht ganz sicher, weil sie das nicht
jeden Tag verwenden, wollen aber nicht zugeben,
dass sie sich nicht ganz sicher sind und
erzählen dir dann erstmal eine halbe Stunde von
ja, also als ich das letzte Mal
eine Grafikausgabe gemacht habe, da war
das überhaupt nicht so gut, weil dann ist das in Putty falsch
dargestellt worden
und warum willst du überhaupt eine Grafik
Ausgabe machen? Ist es nicht meistens
besser zur Lesbarkeit, wenn es sich
an der Konsole orientiert? Und wenn es schon
so anfängt, wenn ich weiß, dass es solche Leute sind,
dann sage ich, ey, scheiß drauf,
ich google jetzt erstmal eine halbe Stunde.
Das klingt ein bisschen nach
typischer Forumsantwort, ja, aber das
kommt ja nicht von ungefähr, dass
Forumsantworten oftmals so sind. Dann google
ich lieber eine halbe Stunde und
lerne wahrscheinlich sogar noch
mehr dabei, weil ich dann in den Google
Antworten lerne, okay, backslash e
ist nicht der einzige Escape Sequenz
dafür und ich sollte übrigens die
Grafikausgabe das irgendwie noch
terminieren und sonst was.
Deswegen, ehrlich gesagt, mit
dem andere Leute fragen, ist so ein ganz
spezielles Thema,
was ich nur in
Fällen mache, wo ich halt
weiß, derjenige, das ist unkompliziert
und der weiß auch, wovon er
spricht. Ich meine, nur weil jemand, sagen
wir mal, im
Team ist, was sich um Zertifikate kümmert,
heißt das noch lang nicht, dass
ich den fragen kann und der mein Problem, also
ich habe die Erfahrung
gemacht, dass man in 80, 90
Prozent der Fälle, wenn man nicht
weiter weiß und die Default
Antwort darauf ist, ich frage jemand,
dass das in 80 bis 90
Prozent der Fälle
entweder nicht zu einem sinnvollen
Ergebnis führt,
also du am Ende auch nicht schlauer bist,
oder es enorm lange
dauert und
ich die Erfahrung gemacht habe, dass man in der Regel
mit
selbst suchen meistens schnell
schneller zum Ziel kommt.
Es sei denn, es ist halt wirklich was ganz
spezielles, wo ich halt gerade schon
versucht habe zu umschreiben.
Weiß nicht, je nachdem,
wenn ich Bock auf Schwätzen habe, rufe ich die an,
wenn ich keinen Bock auf Schwätzen habe, rufe ich die nicht an.
Okay, dann
Geheimnis 3.
Das ist wohl der wichtigste und mit dem habe ich
die ganze Zeit auch noch wirklich zu kämpfen und
der ist gar nicht so einfach umzusetzen.
Aber während meiner Zeit als Softwareentwickler
konnte ich, dass bei den erfolgreichsten
Kollegen feststellen, dass sie diese
Eigenschaft hat.
Und diese Eigenschaft hat sie wahrscheinlich an dem Punkt
Tim, Tim, Tim
Komm, komm zum Punkt, please.
In der IT-Branche gibt es dauerhaft Änderungen.
Es gibt immer wieder neue Programmiersprachen,
neue Tools, neue Frameworks,
neue Konzepte, such dir...
Moment, was meint ihr, wie viele JavaScript
Frameworks wurden heute schon neu auf
GitHub erstellt?
Ich meine heute, heute
europäische Zeit,
also sagen wir mal von in den letzten
12 Stunden.
Es gibt immer was Neues und diese neuen Sachen,
die sind sowieso alle immer besser als
alles, was du davor gelernt hast.
Als ich beispielsweise vor der Herausforderung stand,
aus meinem gewohnten Webentwicklungsumfeld
herauszugehen und jetzt in DevOps und
Cloud-Technologien einzusteigen,
das ist eine gute Idee gewesen von ihm, das zu machen,
habe ich mich anfangs wirklich sehr, sehr
unsicher und einfach richtig schlecht gefühlt.
Das ist normal. Im Cloud-Umfeld
ist es normal, dass man überfordert ist,
weil, also
je nachdem, in welchem Umfeld man da ist,
weil dort IT-Clicks,
50 neue Sachen
spawnen, gerade
die Cloud-Anbieter diesen Campbell auch nicht
einheitlich benennen können, Sachen umbenennen
können. Pakete, letztens
habe ich gesehen, Google hat einfach
eines ihrer Pakete von Google Cloud
SDK in Google Cloud CLI umbenannt.
Es gibt beide Pakete noch und es gibt jetzt
Pakete, es gibt jetzt File-Konflikte,
weshalb auch immer.
Im Cloud-Umfeld
ist jeder planlos.
Mittlerweile weiß ich diese Zeichen aber
anders zu deuten, denn das bedeutet,
eigentlich nur, dass ich mich gerade weiterentwickele
und auch an den Herausforderungen
wachsen kann. Außerdem hat es mir
geholfen, mit Kollegen zu sprechen,
denn da habe ich auch herausgefunden,
dass die sich genauso unsicher fühlen,
wenn sie neue Herausforderungen angehen.
Soll heißen, erfolgreiche Programmierer fühlen
sich wohl damit, sich unwohl
zu fühlen. Naja, das würde ich so nicht unbedingt
unterschreiben. Bei dem Punkt gebe ich
ihm aber prinzipiell recht.
Es ist teilweise
schwierig, sich
von was gewohnten
Aufgabengebieten
zu wechseln.
Ich finde das aber gar nicht so schlimm,
solange es etwas ist, was einen interessiert.
Wenn es etwas ist, was einen persönlich interessiert,
dann ist das alles halb so wild.
Ja, auch gut.
Raspberry Pi 5
NVMe M2 SSD.
Ja, nice, dass es geht.
Das ist dieser
Mikro...
PCI Express
den PCI Express
Steckplatz, den der Raspberry
Pi jetzt hat.
Nice, dass es geht. Praktisch sinnvoll,
wahrscheinlich nur in Grenzen.
Gucken wir uns das nächste Mal an.
Ihr habt ja gesagt, es ist wirklich keine
schlechte Doku.
Wollen wir uns das nächste Mal angucken.
Chat, gibt es noch was
Spannendes diese Woche, was ich noch nicht mitgekriegt
habe, wo wir unbedingt drüber sprechen müssen?
Weil ich mache mir jetzt gleich was zu essen. Ach ja,
die übliche Sache mit, was gibt es heute zu essen?
Wer weiß es? Was?
Ich habe vor ein paar Jahren mein Defizit daheim
nach und jetzt geht das aber nicht mehr und ich
was meinst du? Du meinst, du hast viel
daheim gelernt an Themen
und es geht aus irgendwelchen Gründen jetzt
nicht mehr oder was meinst du? Also
geht das nicht mehr, weil du keine
Zeit hast, weil du keinen Bock mehr hast, weil du
zu beschäftigt bist mit
Familie drumherum? Ist halt so.
Letztendlich, ihr kennt mich,
ich habe es schon oft gesagt,
die meisten neuen Technologien,
die ich bisher gelernt habe,
habe ich auch in meiner
Freizeit gelernt und
konnte sie dann im Nachhinein
öfters mal, nicht bei allem,
ja, ich warte immer noch auf den Zeitpunkt,
wo ich meinen Microcontroller,
meine Microcontroller-Programmierskills
mal auf der Arbeit brauche.
So nach dem Motto,
Max, wir haben schon immer für unser Rack
einen Microcontroller mit Temperatursensor
gebraucht.
Da warte ich ja noch drauf, dass ich das da irgendwann mal
brauche, aber vieles von dem, wofür
ich mich ursprünglich erst privat
beschäftigt habe, habe ich auf der Arbeit
auch sinnig brauchen können.
Hätte ich nicht angefangen, mich mit
den unterschiedlichsten Programmiersprachen,
Frameworks, Web-Anwendungen,
Frontend, Backend, sonst was zu beschäftigen,
was ja eigentlich nicht so die klassische
die klassische
Physi-Sache ist, die ich ja damals gelernt habe,
wäre ich wahrscheinlich nie
im DevOps-Umfeld gelandet,
zu Zeiten, als es das Wort
DevOps noch gar nicht gab.
Und
wäre jetzt nicht dort gelandet, wo ich bin.
Also es ist oftmals
für was gut, ja. Und es ist
nie verschenkt, ich glaube, das kann man auch nicht
so oft genug sagen, es ist nie
verschenkt, wenn euch das was gibt und wenn euch
das gefällt.
Auch wenn ich die, es geht ja nicht
immer nur darum, dass man damit irgendwie
super erfolgreich was im Beruf anfangen kann.
Mein Microcontroller
programmiert Zeug, auch was wir hier schon im
Stream gemacht haben, das Löten und das Basteln,
das macht einfach Bock.
Es bringt daheim was, ja. Ich kann zum
Beispiel meine
den, den die
Wasserzufuhr für die Heizung im Keller
den Druck wieder
ein bisschen zu erhöhen.
Muss man alle halbe Jahr, muss man mal ein bisschen Wasser
nachfüllen. Kann ich beispielsweise jetzt remote
erledigen. Haben wir ja auch im Stream
gebaut, nämlich
eine,
ein Ventilöffner.
Haben wir das im, das haben wir
im Stream gebaut, gell. Das war ein mega
nices Ding.
Ventil.
Es kann aber auch sein, dass es im Stream nicht
funktioniert hat.
Ja. Ja.
Kann auch sein, dass ich es kaputt gemacht habe
oder so.
Zumindest haben wir da
so ein, äh,
so ein, Moment,
smart,
so ein Ding habe ich mir bestellt,
was normalerweise wieder, wie üblich,
nur mit China-Chinesen-Shit funktioniert.
Und dann haben wir
folgendes gemacht, also das ist
so gedacht, guck, wenn man, wenn ihr so ein Ventil habt,
dann setzt ihr das Ding da oben drauf
und da ist ein Motor
drin, das kann das nach links und rechts bewegen.
Und was wir im Stream gemacht haben ist,
wir haben einen
ESP32, äh, was ist denn
das für einer, einen D1 Mini
ist das wahrscheinlich, gell. Es könnte sogar
ein ESP2866 sein, den ich hier
habe. Das ist glaube ich sogar ein ESP2866.
Habe ich an die Steuerungs
Pins dran
gelötet von diesem, von diesem Motor.
Oder nee,
nicht von dem Motor direkt,
einfach nur an die GPIOs
dran gelötet, die den Impuls für starten und stoppen
gibt.
Und jetzt kann ich über
WiFi mit dem Controller
das Ventil auf und zu machen.
Ohne, ohne, dass ich China-Chinesen-
Hardware brauche.
Was mache ich da gerade?
Ich glaube das ging im Stream nicht.
Ich glaube das war broken, ich habe es irgendwie kaputt gemacht.
Hat das denn am Ende funktioniert, was ich da gebaut habe?
Also, mittlerweile
funktioniert es,
weil ich habe es im Keller. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob die
Iteration, die im Stream
die ich im Stream
gebaut habe, ob die funktioniert.
Alter, hatte ich da noch dicke Hände, Mann.
Okay, da war ich auch noch 18 Kilo.
Boah, what the fuck.
Da war ich auch noch 18 Kilo
schwerer. Richtig
Pepo-Fett-Fingers
Alter. Richtig
Chonker-Fingers.
Hat das im Stream funktioniert?
Ich bin mir unschlüssig.
Ich glaube es hat im Stream nicht funktioniert, oder?
Ich glaube das war ein Problem, das hat nicht richtig funktioniert
im Stream.
Weil, weil ich
irgendwie
irgendwas kaputt gemacht habe.
Es hat nicht funktioniert, glaube ich.
Jaja, also wenn ich mit dem
Multimeter anrücke, dann
könnt ihr davon ausgehen, dass es irgendwas kaputt gewesen ist.
Das kommt
immer nur in Notfällen zum Einsatz.
Es hat glaube ich
nie funktioniert im Stream.
Oder hat es am Ende getan?
Nee.
Nee, nee, wenn ich dann nochmal Löt-Action mache.
Ich glaube ich habe es dann
sein gelassen, ja.
Es wird
echt mal wieder Zeit für eine Runde Bastel-Streams,
oder?
Ich habe gerade aktuell nichts zum Basteln.
Aber ich hätte mal wieder Bock auf
Löt-Bastel-Stells im Stream.
Habe ich nicht noch ein paar China-Chinesen-Steckdosen,
die geflasht werden müssen,
die man nicht OTA flashen kann,
so irgendwas. Das geht ja immer.
Die Schredder-Bild.
Ja, mittlerweile funktioniert es.
Ich habe das schon seit über einem Jahr,
oder seit zwei Jahren oder so, weiß nicht, wie lange
der Stream her ist, im Keller.
Funktioniert wunderbar.
Was könnte man mal wieder basteln?
Mir fällt gerade echt nichts ein.
Wo ich Elektronik-Stells
machen müsste.
Stream gibt vor, was du basteln könntest.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber jetzt, wie ich überhaupt noch auf das Thema gekommen bin.
Das ist was, das ist nice in der Heim,
das hat mir auf der Arbeit nie was gebracht,
dass ich Microcontroller basteln kann.
Aber wichtig ist,
es ist nie verschenkt, wenn es einem Spaß macht
und wenn da...
Wer weiß, wofür man das nochmal brauchen kann.
Es gibt auch Sachen,
die machen jetzt nicht unbedingt so Spaß
in Form von
Oh, nice,
wie das geklappt hat oder so,
aber die sind trotzdem sinnvoll.
Auch gut für einen.
Zum Beispiel
sich ein bisschen mehr bewegen.
Auch wenn es an manchen Tagen nicht so viel Spaß macht.
Gießanlage
für Blumen- und Fensteröffner.
Habe ich hier keinen Anwendungsfall für.
Wie kommt man
am besten ins Microcontroller-Game rein?
Spielerisch? Nö, ich habe Heim-Automatisierung
Sachen gebaut. Also das Beste,
was du machen kannst, wenn du einsteigen willst,
ist ein bisschen Microcontroller
Programming.
Dann gehst du zu Amazon.
Holst dir ein ESP32,
wobei Amazon ist ganz schön teuer mittlerweile.
Alter!
What?
Was wollen die dafür haben mittlerweile?
Früher hast du
für 15 Euro 3 Stück gekriegt
und bei AliExpress für 5 Euro.
Sind die komplett
des Wahnsinns mittlerweile.
Ja 3 Stück, das ist ja nix.
Ich habe noch
10er Packs
hier. D1 Mini
ESP32.
Warum ist der Scheiß so teuer geworden?
Boah ey, man AliExpress sieht immer
so krass nach Scam aus.
Das ist doch hier bestimmt ein bisschen günstiger
geworden. Ja hier
kommen wir den preislichen Regionen
schon etwas näher. 1 Euro
pro Stück und sowas.
ESP32 ist ein bisschen teurer.
Also sowas in der Richtung.
Früher hatte doch jemand, wie heißt die?
Arts Delivery.
Hatte früher auf Amazon immer welche.
Ey das ist ja mal
super teuer geworden.
Alter 25 Euro für
Ich meine kann man machen.
Also wenn du ein bisschen Microcontroller Zeug basteln willst.
Natürlich
kannst du dir auch ein Raspberry Pi Pico oder sowas
holen. Der ist es sicherlich
vielleicht ein bisschen
wobei eigentlich gar nicht.
Also ich finde das ist immer noch der beste
Microcontroller zum basteln.
So für alle 0815 Sachen.
Im Prinzip ist es
fast egal.
Hol dir irgendwie 3 Stück davon.
Ich würde mir auch tatsächlich 3 Stück holen.
Weil man macht sowas auch mal relativ schnell kaputt.
Hol dir den ESP32.
Die NodeMCUs sind ganz gut.
Also das hier ist ja der eigentliche
ESP32 hier.
Noch nicht mal das hier.
Der Chip unter diesem Ding
ist der ESP32.
Der Rest ist einfach ein Board was die ganzen
Pins rausführt.
Du hast mehrere Crown Pins.
5 von USB.
Der Rest Ding läuft mit 3,3.
Dann hast du jede Menge GPIO Pins,
I2C Pins und sonstige
Dinger. Also ein ESP32 kann vieles.
Zumindest worauf ich eigentlich raus will.
Wenn du dich für irgendeine Microcontroller
Plattform entschieden hast, dann
Plattform IO. Beste.
Damit kannst du
zum Einstieg nichts falsch machen.
Das ist ein Visual Studio Code Plugin.
Was dir die meiste Arbeit
erstmal abnimmt.
Du kannst im Prinzip Visual Studio Code
starten. Plattform IO installieren.
Dann musst du Visual Studio Code nochmal neu starten.
Dann legst du ein Projekt an. Bei der Projekterstellung
wählst du den Controller aus. Der richtet dir alles ein.
Auch schon
serielle Konsole.
Du kannst flashen einfach mit einem Job in
Visual Studio Code. Du hast ein Projekt
Template. Also Plattform IO macht es wirklich
super simpel. Also wenn du dich da
ein bisschen mit beschäftigen willst, dann
Plattform IO. Und ich finde den ESP32
einfach gut als Einstiegsplattform.
Ach, brauchen wir nicht. Plattform IO. Nehmen
wir Plattform IO.
Arduino IDE ist komplett outdated, overrated.
Plattform IO. Beste.
Kann sich auch Arduino in Plattform IO machen.
Ja Chatge, was meint ihr denn, was es heute
gibt zu essen?
Es ist nicht Nudel mit Lachs.
Es ist Nudel mit Tomatensoße.
Korrekt.
Exzellent.
Ich sehe, der Chat weiß Bescheid.
Deine Frage wurde übersehen.
Echt? Wo denn?
Wo ist das hier? Ich such mal nach dir.
Yellow.
Du hast keine Frage gestellt.
Da, guck.
Eins von eins.
Du hast keine Frage gestellt
in den letzten 40 Minuten.
Oh doch, hast du.
Die Frage habe ich sogar gesehen.
Die ist aber älter als 40 Minuten.
Kannst du
Domainregistrarer empfehlen und
ob ich auf etwas achten sollte?
Ne, kann ich nicht.
Ich bin bei
5 verschiedenen
Domainregistraren.
Ich bin einmal
bei Pork Bun.
Die würde ich aber
gar nicht so sehr empfehlen.
Mittlerweile
haben sie eine gescheite DNS-API für
automatische Zertifikate und sowas hatten sie lange Zeit nicht.
Pork Bun, die sind halt
einfach super billig.
Pork Bun
habe ich. Dann habe ich
Named Cheap.
Nitrado habe ich tatsächlich noch.
Die fragt mich nicht, was mich da gerettet hat.
Cloudflare.
Oh, das war's.
Namesilo.
Namesilo habe ich auch noch welche.
Das ist der größte Schrottladen, ey.
Die haben mir überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Du willst das...
Wie kann ich mir sicher, ohne dass jemand was mitbekommt,
Torrent private Linux-ISOs
runterladen? Natürlich.
Ja, also für Linux-ISOs, nur
für Linux-ISOs logischerweise
ist Torrent vielleicht gar nicht die
beste Idee. Bei Hetzner
hätte ich wahrscheinlich auch ein paar Domains.
Aber die kamen da
gleich wieder mit echtem Namen und
Ausweisgedöns an, da hatte ich keinen Bock drauf.
Ich halte von VPNs
nix. In diesem Fall
kann man sich das aber mal überlegen.
Das ist glaube ich eines der...
Also, sich
Linux-ISOs über Torrents runterladen
und Geoblocking zu umgehen ist
tatsächlich eines der wenigen Sachen, wo ich sagen würde,
hey, dafür ist ein VPN sinnvoll.
Den ganzen restlichen Mist, den
die euch so erzählen mit
ihr seid viel sicherer unterwegs und
was auch immer, wir wehren Hacker für euch
ab und ach, gar nicht. Alles Blödsinn.
Leute,
ich geh jetzt
was essen. Übelst Hunger.
Let's Encrypt machst du eh selbst.
Let's Encrypt geht auf
allen Hosts, auf allen
Domain-Registraten, die eine DNS-API haben.
Let's Encrypt
musst du eh selbst machen, wenn du es richtig machen
willst. Also das Ding ist... Moment, Moment.
Das muss ich jetzt mal kurz erklären.
Es gibt viele Domain-Registrare, die bieten
automatische SSL-Zertifikats-
Generierung an.
Das ist aber kompletter Schwachsinn.
Ihr generiert doch nicht den Private Key
woanders,
um ihn euch dann runterzuladen.
Das Ding heißt nicht umsonst Private Key.
Das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Let's Encrypt beim Anbieter
generieren zu lassen. Null.
Was ihr machen müsst, ist ein Domain-Registrar
euch aussuchen, der eine DNS-API hat.
Oder
noch nicht mal,
wenn ihr nur Public Services
mit Zertifikaten versorgen wollt,
dann könnt ihr auch HTTP-Challenge machen.
Na klar.
Naja, wenn du dort auf
generiere Zertifikat für Domain klickst
und es runterlädst, natürlich generieren die das für dich.
Die machen das, was du machen würdest mit Let's Encrypt
oder Certbot, machen die dann für dich
und du kannst runterladen.
Ihr braucht ein Domain-Registrar,
der DNS-API
hat
und
dann benutzt ihr irgendeinen Let's Encrypt
Client, sei es
Certbot oder ihr benutzt einen Reverse-Proxy,
der das eingebaut hat
und dann macht ihr
DNS-Authentifizierung.
Ja, Certbot ist schon ziemlich Pains-Champ.
Aber dann macht ihr
DNS-Zertifizierung, äh DNS-Zertifizierung
dann macht ihr
Zertifikatsgenerierung
mit Let's Encrypt über DNS-Challenge
und dann könnt ihr
auch Zertifikate generieren für Domains,
die ihr nur rein intern verwendet.
Also ihr könnt euch an der Public Domain registrieren,
kappa-lul-hd.com
und dafür könnt ihr euch Zertifikate
generieren bei rein internen Services
mit DNS-Authentifizierung.
Also mit DNS-Challenge heißt das ja.
Ihr braucht einfach nur ein Domain-Registrar, der DNS-Challenge
unterstützt. DNS-Challenge finde ich ist
für sowas eigentlich immer das Praktischste.
Ja, das haben wir auch im Stream schon gemacht.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich
simpel. Wenn ihr wollt, können wir
das nochmal machen.
In easy.
Wenn ihr wollt, können wir das nochmal machen.
Ja, und
dann ist es
egal, ob dein Domain-Registrar Let's Encrypt
unterstützt oder nicht.
Es gibt keine Let's Encrypt
Unterstützung, die ein Domain-Registrar
anbieten muss. Ein Domain-Registrar
macht zwei Sachen.
Der macht erstmal eine Sache, aber meistens
machen sie zwei Sachen.
Der registriert die
Domain für euch
und der stellt ein DNS bereit.
Streng genommen sind das zwei unterschiedliche
Paar Schuhe, aber meistens ist das so.
So, und
wie das funktioniert
von der Theorie her
mit Let's Encrypt
ist folgendes. Es muss ja übrigens
auch nicht Let's Encrypt sein, deswegen der Anbieter muss
das nicht unterstützen. Wichtig ist, dass sie eine DNS-API
haben. So, das funktioniert dann
folgendermaßen. Ihr habt einen Raspberry Pi
daheim, der ein gültiges Zertifikat bekommen
soll für kappa0hd.com.
Ihr registriert euch
kappa0hd.com
bei einem
x-beliebigen Domain-Registrar
und dann nehmt ihr einen Let's Encrypt Client.
Zum Beispiel Certbot. Es gibt noch
jede Menge andere. Ihr könnt auch
einen Proxy nehmen, der das schon eingebaut ist.
Egal, nehmen wir mal Certbot.
Let's Encrypt Client xy.
Das ist vollkommen egal welcher.
Dadurch, dass ihr intern seid, könnt ihr
nicht die normale HTTP Challenge machen.
Die normale HTTP Challenge
bei Let's Encrypt
sieht folgendermaßen aus.
Ihr habt einen Linux-Server oder einen Server
und ihr stellt
bei eurem Domain-Registrar ein.
Hinter
www.kappa0hd.com
ist halt die Public-IP
von eurem Server.
Darauf startet ihr den Web-Server.
Der Web-Server fragt ein Zertifikat
bei Let's Encrypt an.
Let's Encrypt macht eine DNS-Auflösung
zu
der
IP, wo der Web-Server
von euch steht.
Let's Encrypt erwartet, dass dort
auf diesem Web-Server eine Datei
liegt mit einem Secret,
was sich der Client und Let's Encrypt
im Step davor ausgemacht haben.
Wenn
die Datei mit diesem Secret auf dem Web-Server
liegt, dann beweist das für Let's Encrypt,
dass ihr Eigentümer der Domain seid.
Ansonsten
würde die Domain nicht auf euch auflösen.
Das funktioniert aber nur bei Public-Servern.
Wenn ihr jetzt einen
internen Service habt,
so einen Raspberry Pi, der eure
registrierte Domain benutzt,
dann müsst ihr die DNS-Challenge machen.
Die DNS-Challenge funktioniert so.
Ihr benutzt einen Let's Encrypt-Client,
der geht zu Let's Encrypt
und sagt, ich hätte gerne für
kappa0hd.com ein Zertifikat.
Dann machen die
ein gemeinsames, geheimes Passwort
ein geheimes Secret miteinander aus.
Und dann
muss
der DNS-Server
für diese Domain,
für das ihr das Zertifikat
ausstellen wollt,
muss einen TXT-Record anbieten
mit dem vorher ausgemachten Secret.
Und meistens
funktioniert das so,
dass der Let's Encrypt-Client
eben verschiedene Anbieter
unterstützt.
Sei es jetzt Cloudflare
oder Namecheap oder was auch immer.
Damit das die verschiedenen
Domain-Registrare unterstützen.
Und über die DNS-API
von diesen Domain-Registraren
dann diesen TXT-Record
mit dem Secret hinterlegt.
Das ist nicht zwingend notwendig,
ihr könnt das auch von Hand machen.
Also es gibt auch so einen Manual-Mode,
dann könnt ihr quasi selbst
in das Webinterface gehen,
das Secret hinterlegen
und dann sagen, jawohl
das Secret ist da und Let's Encrypt guckt,
ist das Secret das, was ausgemacht wurde?
Dann gibt es euch ein Zertifikat.
So, das ist eigentlich so der Ablauf
von DNS-Challenge.
Das dumme ist nur, wenn es nicht
automatisch über die API geht,
von eurem Domain-Registrar
oder besser gesagt von dem,
wo ihr auch immer euren DNS-Server
laufen habt,
dann ist es schwierig mit
automatischer Erneuerung.
Und Let's Encrypt stellt ja nur Zertifikate aus,
die maximal 3 Monate,
früher waren bis zu einem halben Jahr,
ich glaube mittlerweile nur noch 3 Monate,
und wenn das nicht automatisch geht
und immer nur mit einem manuellen Step,
ist doof.
Deswegen,
ihr braucht eine DNS-API,
aber das kann mittlerweile
so gut wie jeder Domain-Registrar.
Explizit Let's Encrypt unterstützen müssen die nicht
und ich würde auch ganz dringend davon abraten,
Zertifikate dort generieren zu lassen
und sie mir anschließend runterzuladen.
Einfach selbst Let's Encrypt machen,
das ist easy mittlerweile,
das kriegt jeder hin,
ich werde es auch das nächste Mal
nochmal im Stream machen,
da habe ich sogar ein Thema,
was ich aus dem Ärmel schütteln kann
und schnell gemacht ist,
für Technik-Course-Stream,
und dann ist gut.
So, ich geh jetzt wirklich was essen,
Leute, wir sehen uns,
vielleicht bin ich nachher noch
mit den letzten Zügen des PvP-Events
unterwegs, hier auf Twitch,
das interessiert natürlich dann nicht so viele Leute,
aber die einen oder anderen gucken ja trotzdem
mal mit Delay,
da muss ich schon so 3 Minuten mal 3 Minuten
Stream-Delay machen,
weil
PvP mit Stream-Snipping
war ja nicht so geil.
Muss ich mal nachher gucken,
aber das dann erst heute Nachmittag,
wenn überhaupt.
Ich hätte aber mal wieder Bock drauf,
aber mit Delay, ich streame so ungern mit Delay,
aber es geht nicht anders,
als mit Delay zu streamen.
Na gut,
Moin,
ich bin jetzt aber auch weg,
ich geh jetzt was futtern,
bis denn, machts gut, see you.